SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER ONE WILL
COME TO ORDER- AND I'M GOING TO
GO THROUGH OUR GROUND RULES
WHICH IF YOU HAVEN'T HEARD THEM
BEFORE YOU HAVEN'T BEEN
LISTENING. SO IN RESPONSE TO
THE COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERING SYNOD HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTRICT DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS. HERE IN THE CAPITAL
COMMITTEE ARE HERE OR WE EXPECT
TO BE HERE I AM JOINED BY
SENATOR MAN RIGHT NOW- AND THE
DOOR OPENED AND I AM ALSO
JOINED BY SENATOR OCHO BROKE SO
WE HAVE- EVERY COMMITTEE MEMBER
HERE. OF THOSE PROVIDING
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. FOR REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK I ASKED THAT
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU USED TO
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WANT TO ON MUTE. POLICE
SELECTOR ON MUTE BEFORE YOU
BEGIN SPEAKING AND FOR THOSE OF
YOU JOINING US AND CONFERENCE.
A TELECONFERENCE ON MUTING IS
IMPORTANT THERE ALSO- ARE I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
YOU WHEN YOU'RE DONE ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOU'RE READY. TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS. WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. THE THAT'S
THIS ROOM AND ROOMS TWENTY
FORTY. WE'LL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TEST TESTIFIED TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE. IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT
NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE
ONE. FOUR ONE EIGHT FIVE. AND
THE ACCESS CODE. HIS. THREE
THREE EIGHT ZERO FOUR SIX SEVEN
NINE IS ON THE SCREEN RIGHT NOW.
FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW THE TELECONFERENCES TO
MARKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE AND OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
AND ALSO FOR PEOPLE ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE PLEASE NOTE
THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR
YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING ON
THE HEARING PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. BUT
DON'T MUTE YOURSELF ARE IT'S
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHOSE DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MADE. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS%
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE.
OF ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT. SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. TODAY IS
THE TENTH HEARING. ARE THAT WE
HAVE HAD SINCE WE STARTED
HEARING SINCE FEBRUARY. TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HEAR ALL THE ITEMS
PRIOR TO THE RELEASE OF THE MAY
REVISE WE WILL BE HAVING A
HEARING TOMORROW AFTERNOON.
JOINTLY WITH THE BUDGET SUB ON
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES. AND
ON APRIL THIRTEENTH THE SENATE
RELEASED THE BILL BACK BOLDLY
BUDGET PLAN. WHICH HIGHLIGHTS
THE SENATE'S VARIOUS BUDGET
PRIORITIES AS WE MOVE INTO THE
MAY REVISION. OF THE PLAN SEEKS
TO ACCESS. HER THIS IS A SIX TO
INCREASE ACCESS AND
AFFORDABILITY HIGHER EDUCATION
AND TO HELP BUILD A STRONGER
MIDDLE CLASS. AND AS AN
EDITORIAL WE LISTED EIGHT ITEMS
OUT AND YOU CAN PICK OFF THIS
WEEK AS THE GOVERNOR ROLLS OUT.
HIS BUDGET HOW HE IS ADDRESSING
MANY OF THE ISSUES THAT THE
SENATE POINT OUT A FEW WEEKS
AGO. SO TODAY'S HEARING WILL
COVER THE VARIOUS HIGHER
EDUCATION PROPOSALS IN THE
SENATE BILL BACK BOLDLY BUDGET.
INCLUDING PUBLIC LIBRARY
SUPPORT UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY UNDERGRADUATE
ENROLLMENT AND DEBT FREE
COLLEGE. THESE ITEMS ARE FOR
INFORMATIONAL PURPOSES NO VOTES
WILL BE TAKEN TODAY PUBLIC
COMMENT WILL BE AT THE END OF
THE MEETING ONCE WE HAVE HEARD.
ALL DISCUSSION ITEMS WITH THAT
SENATE ROADSHOW BOGOR SENATOR
MINDY OF ANY OPENING COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE WE WILL MOVE RIGHT
ON TO OUR FIRST ITEM. WE HAVE
THREE ITEMS ON THE AGENDA TODAY
THE FIRST ITEM IS LIBRARY
SUPPORT. AND R. THREE WITNESSES
ARE JASON CONSTANT TOURISTS FOR
TOURISTS FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE GREG LUCAS THE
STATE LIBRARIAN AND JENNIFER
LOUIS FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. BRIANNA BROWN'S FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WILL
ALSO JUST BE AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS WITH THAT ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAKERS JASON
GREG AND JENNIFER IN THAT
ORDER. AND ARE WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE MR CONSTANT TOUR. ALL
RIGHT JASON CONTRERAS HELLO. ON
THIS ITEM AS NOTED FOCUSES ON
STATE SUPPORT FOR LOCAL PUBLIC
LIBRARIES AS YOUR AGENDA NOTES
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN CALIFORNIA
ARE THE PRIMARY SOURCE OF
FUNDING FOR LOCAL PUBLIC
LIBRARIES WITH LOCAL FUNDING
COMPRISING ABOUT 95% OF LOCAL
LIBRARY OPERATING BUDGETS OTHER
REMAINING 5% IS SHARED BETWEEN
STATE AND FEDERAL SOURCES AND A
FEW OTHER SOURCES. NOW THIS
ITEM FOR YOU CONSISTS OF TWO
COMPONENTS OF THE SENATE
DEMOCRATS BUDGET PLAN. THE
FIRST IS FUNDING FOR LIBRARY
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE SECOND
IS FUNDING FOR LIBRARY
OPERATIONS AND SERVICES SO I
WILL TOUCH ON EACH COMPONENT
AND IN BOTH CASES PROVIDE A
LITTLE BIT OF- BACKGROUND AS
WELL. FIRST AND THEN ON THE
INFRASTRUCTURE SIDE THE SENATE
DEMOCRATS BUDGET PLAN PROVIDES-
ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR LIBRARY
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND ACCORDING
TO STAFF ON INFRASTRUCTURE HERE
IT WOULD BE PROBABLY TO FIND IT
SO IT WOULD INCLUDE CAPITAL
OUTLAY WOULD INCLUDE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE WOULD INCLUDE
PROJECTS TO EXPAND- INTERNET
ACCESS IN BROADBAND CAPACITY OF
INCLUDE EQUIPMENT PURCHASES
THINGS OF THAT NATURE FOR LOCAL
LIBRARIES. OUR STAFF IS ALSO
KNOWN TO US THAT SPECIFIC FUND
SOURCE OF THE WONDER DOLLARS IS
STILL BEING- FIVE TEN FINALIZE
IT'LL BE FINALIZED AFTER ME
REVISION. BUT THAT THE FUND A
FUNDING MIGHT BE A MIX OF-
STATE GENERAL FUND AND- SOME
FEDERAL RELIEF FUNDS. AND JUST
FOR SOME CONTEXT HERE THE STATE
HAS IN PREVIOUS YEARS PROVIDED
SOME FUNDING FOR LIBRARY
INFRASTRUCTURE. ALL THE MOST
NOTABLE SOURCES INCLUDE- TO
VOTER APPROVED BONDS ONE IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT AND THEN
ONE AND IN TWO THOUSAND SO
THESE ARE- OVER TWENTY YEARS
AGO. AND THEN IN MORE RECENT
YEARS SINCE TWENTY FOURTEEN
FIFTEEN THE STATE HAS BEEN
PROVIDING SOME ONGOING FUNDING-
TO IMPROVE THE LIBRARIES ACCESS
TO THE INTERNET. AND THEN ON
THE SECOND COMPONENT FOR-
DIRECT LABOR SUPPORT. I'M HERE
THIS COMPONENT STATUS NOTED IT
THAT THE FINAL- I'M NOT A
FUNDING THAT'S PROVIDED
LIBRARIES IS STILL BEING
DETERMINED THEY'LL BE FINALIZED
AFTER THE REVISION. OF WHAT THE
IDEA HERE IS THAT THE FUNDING
WOULD GO TO LOCAL LIBRARIES
DIRECTLY AND SUPPORT THEIR
GENERAL OPERATIONS. AS A
CONDITION OF RECEIVING THESE
FUNDS LIBRARIES WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO ELIMINATE- THEIR
EXISTING POLICIES ENACTED.
FINES AND FEES ON PATRONS WHO-
RETURN THEIR LIBRARY MATERIALS
AND BOOKS LATE. I CAN HEAR FOR
CONTEXT HISTORICALLY THE STATE
HAS PROVIDED SUPPORT TO LOCAL
LIBRARIES THROUGH TWO DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS AND THERE ARE
DESCRIBED ON PAGE FOUR FIVE
YEAR AGENDA. ALL THE FIRST
PROGRAM IS THE CALIFORNIA
LIBRARY SERVICES ACT THAT
PROGRAM FOCUSES. ON RESOURCE
SHARING SO IT SUPPORTS
ACTIVITIES LIKE INTERLIBRARY
LOANS AND ACQUISITION OF WHAT
TRONIC RESOURCES. ON THE
SECOND. OF PROGRAM. IS THE
PUBLIC LIBRARY FOUNDATION ACT.
OF WHICH PROVIDE A MORE DIRECT
SUPPORT FOR LIBRARY OPERATIONS-
IS YOUR JANET NOTES BOTH OF
THESE PROGRAMS WERE DEFUNDED
DURING THE GREAT RECESSION TO
HELP ADDRESS THE STATE'S BUDGET
SITUATION. SINCE THAT TIME THE
STATE HAS RISEN FUNDING FOR
CERTAIN COMPONENTS OF THE
CALIFORNIA LIBRARY SERVICES
ACT- BUT IS NOT REGION FUNDING
FOR THE FOUNDATION PROGRAM.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MISTER LUCAS WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU- GREG
LUCAS FROM THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LIBRARY- I JUST WANT TO START
BY SAYING THAT I APPRECIATE-
SENTENCE BUDGET PLAN. I THINK
BY FROM ANY OBJECTIVE MEASURE-
THERE'S A LOT OF THE ONGOING
BENEFIT OF ONE TIME MONEY IS
INCREASED SIGNIFICANTLY BY
INVESTING AND- THE SOCIAL AND
PHYSICAL INFRASTRUCTURE WE NEED
TO GROW RESPONSIBLY AND SUCCEED
ECONOMICALLY. SO- BUT WITH THAT
SAID- GOOD GOOD LIBRARIES HAVE
TWO BILLION DOLLARS INSTEAD OF
ONE BILLION DOLLARS- I JUST
THINKING BACK ON WHAT JASON
SAID- AT THE REQUEST OF THE
RESEARCH BEAR WENT OUT IN APRIL
AND DID A SURVEY OF LIBRARIES
AND IN A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME
WE GOT AN ESTIMATE FOR THE
RENOVATION- RECONSTRUCTION-
REHABILITATION NEEDS OF ABOUT
70% OF THE LIBRARY FACILITIES
IN THE STATE. AND THAT'S ABOUT
THREE POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS OF WHICH THREE HUNDRED
AND FORTY FIVE MILLION IF MY
MEMORY SERVES- DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE SO FIGURE IF YOU
ADD THE OTHER ELSE THAT'S
MISSING 30% LET'S SAY YOU KNOW
THE TOTAL NEED IS PROBABLY
CLOSER TO FIVE BILLION DOLLARS.
AND A COUPLE OF OTHER THINGS
STRUCK ME IN THE SURVEY RESULTS
AND- A NEED IS SOME KIND OF
SUMMARY TOUCHES ON THIS. IS
THAT FUNCTIONALLY A LARGE
PERCENTAGE OF LIBRARIES ARE
TWENTY YEARS OF AGE. AND BUT
THAT DOESN'T. THAT DOESN'T MEAN
THEY WERE BUILT TWENTY YEARS
AGO THAT MEANS THEY WERE BUILT
YOU KNOW SOMETIME AGO AND HAVE
BEEN REMODELED SUBSEQUENTLY SO
THAT FROM A QUOTA BOTH
FUNCTIONAL STANDPOINT THERE
TWENTY YEARS OF AGE. BUT EVEN
IF THERE TWENTY YEARS OF AGE-
BUT THERE ARE CERTAIN
DEFICIENCIES THAT- THE OLDER
BUILDINGS TACK RIGHT SO MANY
WERE GRANDFATHERED IN UNDER THE
AMERICANS WITH DISABILITIES ACT
IF YOU BRING A I'M TOLD IF YOU
BRING UP BATHROOM UP TO
COMPLIANCE- THAT CAN COST. AT
LEAST ONE TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS OR MORE- OLDER
BUILDINGS AREN'T AS ENERGY
EFFICIENT HAS MORE MODERN BUILT.
AND I THINK PARTICULARLY IN
CONNECTION WITH THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY IN THE GOVERNOR'S
COMMITMENT TO. IMPROVING
BROADBAND CONNECTIVITY AND
CONNECTING CALIFORNIANS TO THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO SUCCEED
RIGHT TRYING TO CLOSE THE
OPPORTUNITY GAP- AN ENORMOUS
ISSUE IS THE WIRING IN THESE
OLDER BUILDINGS THAT CAN
ACCOMMODATE THE KIND OF HI
SPEED BROADBAND CONNECTIVITY
THAT'S REQUIRED- IN OUR
INCREASINGLY DIGITAL AGE. AND
YOU KNOW IT'S NOT REAL
GLAMOROUS BUT TO MAKE THE
COMMITMENTS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSING IN THE AREA OF
BROADBAND- YOU HAVE TO HAVE
BUILDINGS AND FACILITIES THAT
ARE BRINGING IN THE HIGHER
SPEED AS OPPOSED TO OLDER
BUILDINGS THAT ARE MORE LIKE
THE FINAL. AND AGAIN LIKE THE
EIGHT LIKE THE BATHROOMS UNDER
ABA IT'S NOT IT'S NOT CHEAP SO
WE JUST USED GRANT MONEY- TO
HELP THE BANNING LIBRARY
BANNING BEAUMONT IT'S ON
INTERSTATE TEN AS YOU'RE GOING
OUT. TO THE PALM SPRINGS-
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND SQUARE
FOOT BUILDING SINGLE STORY SO
IT'S NOT A TERRIBLY COMPLICATED
PROJECT. BUT HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO DO THE REQUIRE. AND
SO IF YOU IF YOU ASSUME HALF OF
THE STATE'S ELEVEN HUNDRED
LIBRARIES. REQUIRED BETTER
WIRING TO ACCOMMODATE HIGHER
SPEED BROADBAND. WELL THAT'S AT
A HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
SIX HUNDRED LIBRARIES BUT
SOMETHING ON THE ORDER OF SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS JUST IN AND OF
ITSELF. SO I CAN I DON'T TO
TAKE MORE TIME I COULDN'T SPEAK
TO THE OTHER- FUNDING ISSUES IF
YOU'D SENATOR. OVER THE OTHER
SENATORS ON THE PANEL HAVE
QUESTIONS GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I KNOW HIM AND HAVE A
QUESTION OR TWO BUT- THAT'S
GREAT. AND THEN WILL MOVE TO
JENNIFER LOUIS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. GOOD
MORNING AT GENERALLY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- I AM AN
AVAILABLE AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS ON THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSALS ON THE STATE
LIBRARY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR- COMPREHENSIVE FOR A
PRESENTATION. I APPRECIATE IT
VERY MUCH THANKS FOR BEING HERE
LET ME ASK OF THE STATE
LIBRARIAN- A QUESTION OR TWO
BUT FIRST. LET ME JUST SAY
THAT- I THINK THAT THESE ITEMS
ARE SO SELF EXPLANATORY WORTHY
OF SUPPORT I'M GLAD THAT WE'RE
HEARING THEM TODAY I DON'T FEEL
THE NEED TO ASK ANY QUESTIONS
ON THE ITEMS THAT ARE IN FRONT
OF US BUT ON TWO OTHER ITEMS
FOR THE STATE LIBRARIANS- ONE
IS AS YOU TALKED ABOUT HOW OUT
DATED SOME OF THE LIBRARY
BUILDINGS ARE. OF THE STATUTE
THAT SORT OF SETS FORTH THE
DUTIES OF THE STATE LIBRARY AND
ALSO SEEMS TO ME TO BE A LITTLE
OUTDATED DO YOU THINK OVER TIME
MAYBE NEXT YEAR WE SHOULD BE
CONSIDERING US SOME UPDATES TO
THAT. WELL WHAT THE SHORT IN
THE SHORT ANSWER IS YES THE
MAIN CALIFORNIA'S OPERATING
UNDER A LIBRARY SERVICES ACT
THAT WAS WRITTEN IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN SO MANY OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES AND CHALLENGES
THAT WE FACE TODAY WHATEVER
THAT IS FORTY THREE YEARS
LATER- ARE REALLY COVERED IN
THAT LEGISLATION I MEAN WE
RECENTLY- AMENDED INTO YOU KNOW
ADD A DIGITAL COMPONENT TO IT
BUT- AND SO JASON WAS REFERRING
TO THE PUBLIC LIBRARY
FOUNDATION ACT. I MEAN THAT'S-
FUNDING FORMULA THAT'S A
STRATEGY THAT WAS CREATED IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE AND EIGHTY
TWO. I THINK I THINK. I MEAN
JUST TO SORT OF. YOUR BILL ON
ON WHAT YOU WERE SAYING SENATOR
I MEAN WHAT WHAT WE MAY HAVE
AND I WOULD SAY YEAH DON'T JUST
OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD I MEAN A
LOT OF THINGS BESIDES THE COLOR
OF MY HAIR CHANGED OVER THE
PAST FORTY YEARS. AND MAYBE THE
PRIORITIES AND THAT WERE
ADDRESSED IN LEGISLATION FROM
THAT PERIOD ARE HAVE EITHER
BANNED ADDRESSED OR AREN'T AS
HIGH A PRIORITY AS OTHER
PRIORITIES THAT THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR- SEE TODAY.
OKAY THANK YOU EN M. S. YOUR
QUESTION WAS THAT YOU KNOW YOU
DID AND I THINK YOU SET UP MY
PROMISE WHICH IS I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU OVER THE
IF NOTHING ELSE IN THE FALL TO
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT AND SEE IF
THERE'S THINGS WORTH DOING
ALTHOUGH. IT IS VERY DANGEROUS
TO START TALKING ABOUT THE
COLOR OF PEOPLE'S HAIR AND- AND
WHETHER THEY HAVE ANY FROM THE
SEVENTIES SO- JUST FOR THE
RECORD- AND THEN. THE OTHER
QUESTION I WAS GOING TO ASK YOU
WHICH IS NOT A CHEN DIES TO BUT
IS SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE A
REQUEST ON. AND MIGHT LOOK AT
IS. IS THE LIBRARY
ADMINISTERED. I DID MY TO. I
DON'T KNOW IF IT'S A LIBRARY
MAYBE IT WAS THE ARCHIVES
ADMINISTERED GRANTS FOR
ARCHIVES TO THE LGBT
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE STATE
WAS THAT YOU WERE WAS THAT THE
OR CARDS- THAT WAS THAT WAS THE
STATE LIBRARY IT WAS- MEMBERS-
I REQUEST BY THE- THE
LEGISLATURE. AND THERE I'VE
FORGOTTEN WHAT THAT IS TWO
YEARS AGO I WON YES AND THERE
WAS SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND IT WAS ALL
SPENT AND THERE'S AN INCREASED
DEMAND AND THERE'S A REQUEST
FOR A MILLION DOLLARS THIS YEAR
SO. IF WE IF THAT SHOWS UP IN
THE MAY REVISE SORTS ADDED YOU
WOULD BE PREPARED TO ADMINISTER
THOSE GRANTS AGAIN RIGHT. BUT
YES WAY WE DID IT BEFORE WE'RE
HAPPY TO DO IT AGAIN I MEAN
THERE'S LIKE. I WOULD. NOT TO-
DIMINISH THEIR REQUEST OR THEIR
NEED. BUT THERE'S ANY NUMBER OF
OTHER ARCHIVAL GROUPS IN
MUSEUMS AND HISTORICAL
SOCIETIES THAT. HAVE SIMILAR
SIMILAR NEEDS SO I AM REALLY
AWARE IF THAT THERE'S SOMEBODY
THAT PROWSE THROUGH OUR CARDS
SO TO BE HAPPY TO. NO I WILL
WANT TO WORK ON THAT AS WELL SO
THANK YOU FOR RESPONSE. NUMBER
ALMOST ANY QUESTIONS ON THIS
SIDE SENATOR MAN OR TROUBLED.
SECRETIVE THEN WE'RE GOING TO
SAY ROACH BOGO AND SENT MEANT.
WHERE THAT OKAY THEN I'LL GO
THE SENATOR MEN. HI I WANTED TO
ASK- A BIT ABOUT- THE FEE
RELIEF AND ITS GOALS I
UNDERSTAND THAT PART OF THE
PURPOSE OF THIS IS AS EQUITY
AND I APPRECIATE THAT BUT I
WONDER IF WE'RE CREATING A
SITUATION WHERE- YOU KNOW I
GREW UP IN A TIME WHEN WE YOU
KNOW KNEW THAT IF WE RETURN OUR
BOOKS LATE WE- ENCOURAGE THOSE
FEES AND THAT WAS A DETERRENT
TO ME RETURN THOSE BOOKS LATE
AS A KID. AS AN ADULT- AND THAT
WAS ONE OF THE WAYS IN WHICH
OUR LOCAL LIBRARIES KEPT
POPULAR BOOKS IN STOCK MAKE
SURE THAT YOU KNOW I MIGHT HAVE
TO WAIT A WEEK BUT I DON'T HAVE
TO WAIT A MONTH OR TWO MONTHS
OR THREE MONTHS FOR. THE LATEST
COOL BOOK THAT WE ALL WANTED TO
CHECK OUT AND I WONDER IF
PARTICULARLY IN THOSE AREAS
THAT ARE CATERING TO LOWER
INCOME COMMUNITIES IF THIS
MIGHT HAVE A PERVERSE RESULT
OF- ACTUALLY CREATING MORE BOOK
ANSWERS- JUST BY. KIND OF
GETTING RID OF ANY. INCENTIVES
TO ACTUALLY. THOSE BOOKS ON
TIME. IN I GUESS A BIG MIKE MY
QUESTION IS COULD WE DO THIS
MORE TAILORED. IF THE GOAL IS
TO PROVIDE TARGETED RELIEF
COULD WE JUST TARGET. A CERTAIN
HOUSEHOLDS AND COMMUNITIES AND
PROVIDE THEM WITH THE RELIEF.
RATHER THAN A BLANKET POLICY
THAT THAT MIGHT LEAD TO SOME
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES- AND
I'M NOT SURE THAT QUESTIONS FOR
BUT- PROBABLY ANY OF THEM. I
GUESS THIS IS A MORAL HAZARD
QUESTION AT THE END OF THE DAY
IT LOOKS LIKE MR LUCAS'S
PREPARED TO PLUNGE INTO THE
MORAL HAZARD TERRITORY. I SEE.
I'M GLAD TO KNOW THAT I AM-
WELL I THINK CERTAINLY THAT YOU
KNOW ABOUT THE PROPOSAL COULD
BE MORE NARROWLY TAILORED THE
EXPERIENCE HAS NOT BEEN- WHAT
WHAT YOU'RE DESCRIBING SENATOR
I MEAN IT'S BANNED. IT'S BEEN
THERE THERE BEEN A GREATER
NUMBER OF RETURNS OF ITEMS AND
HIGHER LIBRARY USE BY
ABANDONING THE FEES AND I HEAR
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING I IT IS ONE
OF THEM WAS THE SAME THING IN
MY YOUTH RIGHT LIKE THAT WAS AN
INCENTIVE. THE YOU KNOW TO
HONOR THE BARGAIN THAT I'VE
MADE WITH THE LIBRARY THE TO
RETURN THE MATERIALS ON TIME
JUST LET ME ASK A FOLLOW UP
QUESTION IS WHAT YOU'RE REALLY
SAYING. THAT THIS IS COUNTER
INTUITIVE THAT IS THAT- THE
PEOPLE ARE MORE RESPONSIVE
WITHOUT THE FEES. YEAH IT WAS
VERY IT WAS SURPRISING TO ME.
WE WE'VE GOT A- A NEWER
EMPLOYEE AT THE LIBRARY WHO
CAME FROM COLORADO SO THEY DID
A LOT OF WORK IN COLORADO
ABANDONED- THE FEES AND FOUND
OUT THAT INSTEAD OF- YOU KNOW
HAVING MORE BOOKS NOT RETURNED
MORE BOOKS WERE RETURNED IN A
TIMELY MANNER AND THERE'S OTHER
ISSUES TO NOW WITH- WITH THE
PANDEMIC- WHERE- IT'S THE YOU
KNOW A LOT OF THE EFFORT THAT
GOES INTO GETTING THIS MONEY
BACK CAN OFTEN BE MORE
EXPENSIVE THAN. THE MONEY
THAT'S AT ISSUE- HAS A TERRIFIC
REPORT. I NEED TO REFERENCE
THAT IN THE IN THE RIGHT UP
FROM. THE SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
LIBRARY SYSTEM BUT TOOK A LOOK
AT THIS AND- THE IN EQUITY
ISSUES YOU DESCRIBE SENATOR AS
WELL AS SORT OF THE PRACTICAL
IMPACT OF REDUCING THE FEATS.
BUT I YOU KNOW IN. YEAH IN THE
AGGREGATE THERE'S ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING WRONG WITH- TAILORING
SOMETHING. YOU KNOW MORE MORE
NARROWLY RIGHT- AND I AM ALSO
NOT AT A 100% SURE WHETHER.
THERE OUGHT TO BE A BLANKET
PROHIBITION AGAINST. I MEAN
DOES THAT CONSTITUTE A STATE
MANDATE THAT RIGHT THE RESULTS
IN THE ABILITY OF LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS SAYING WELL HEY
YOU'RE IMPOSE THIS ON US YOU'RE
NOT PROVIDING GO TO COVERAGE.
YOU KNOW WE'RE TAKING IN THE-
WHATEVER IT'S CALLED STATE
MANDATE COURT. HI I SUSPECT THE
DOUGH AND STATE MANDATE QUARTER
NOT TERMS THAT FINANCE WOULD
USE IN THEIR PRESENTATION YEAH
I JUST THREE HUNDRED MEN BUT A
QUICK FOLLOW UP I MEAN IT'S SO
WITH THIS WAS AND IT WAS JUST
IN SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC LIBRARY
OR SURVEYS THERE IS THERE ARE
MORE DATA WHAT WHAT WAS THE-
AND I GUESS I COULD JUST LOOK
UP THE REPORT AT SOME POINT BUT
IF YOU COULD DESCRIBE SIR
WHAT'S- WHAT'S A SAMPLE SIZE
HERE. THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
BECAUSE I'M HAPPY YEAH I'M
HAPPY TO I MEAN THERE'S A
NUMBER OF JURISDICTIONS AROUND
THE STATE. CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
SAN FRANCISCO. THERE'S A NUMBER
OF MEN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA I
WANT TO SAY THE LA. CITY
LIBRARY SYSTEM. AS OPPOSED TO
THE COUNTY- A LOT OF THEM HAVE
GOTTEN RID OF FEES- ONE
PRIMARILY YOU KNOW BECAUSE THE
EQUITY ISSUES- BUT TO BECAUSE
OF THE EFFORT INVOLVED IN
TRYING TO- GET BACK TO THAT
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT. IS IN. A
MAJOR PORTION OF THEIR
OPERATING BUDGETS AND IT ALWAYS
AS YOU'RE SUGGESTING SENATOR I
MEAN FOR A SMALL OR LIBRARY
JURISDICTION RIGHT AS OPPOSED
TO LA CITY WHICH HAS BEEN A
COUPLE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET- YOU KNOW THOSE SORT OF
REVENUE STREAMS LOOK DIFFERENT.
YES BY THE LIBRARIES THE
LIBRARY JURISDICTIONS THAT HAVE
GOTTEN RID OF THE FEES LARGE
AND SMALL HAS LARGELY BEEN AN
INCREASE IN USAGE AND A RETURN
OF. OF MATERIALS THAT
PREVIOUSLY HADN'T COME BACK TO
THE LIBRARY MISTER LUCAS I WAS
GONNA ASK IF YOU CAN PROVIDE.
THE INFORMATION ON A LINK OR
REPORT TO SAN FRANCISCO AND THE
OTHERS IF RELEVANT TO THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AND SHE COULD
PROVIDE IT TO THE DIFFERENT
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THAT OF
SENATOR MENDED THAT COMPLETE
YOUR QUESTION I DID I HAD ONE
OTHER QUICK FOLLOW UP- I GUESS
I WAS JUST WONDERING IS THIS.
PARTICULAR BUDGET ALLOCATION
I'M NOT FOR THAT LIBRARY
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA I
PARTICULARLY AS WE THINK ABOUT
MOVING FORWARD- YOU KNOW YOU
GUYS KNOW THIS BETTER THAN I DO
BUT BUT WONDER WHAT IS A
LIBRARIAN FUTURE LOOK LIKE- YOU
KNOW I AM SURE THAT SOMETHING
YOU ALL THOUGHT A LOT ABOUT BUT
WHAT. ONE OF THE DEBATE WHETHER
THE INFRASTRUCTURE AND
TECHNOLOGY AND- YOU KNOW IF WE
TALK ABOUT BUILDING BACK BETTER
WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE FOR
LIBRARIES AND DO WE HAVE- IS
THIS SOMETHING. THAT YOU FEEL
LIKE SATISFIES YOUR NEEDS. THE
IS CRAIG LUCAS- WELL THAT'S A
TERRIFIC QUESTION I MEAN- THE
LIBRARY OF THE FUTURE- I MEAN
WE'RE SEEING THAT TAKING PLACE
IN COMMUNITIES AROUND
CALIFORNIA NOW SO LIBRARIES
HAVE BECOME IT IT MEAN WITH
RESPECT TO COMMUNITY CENTERS
KIND OF WHAT COMMUNITY CENTERS
WISH THEY COULD. SO
INCREASINGLY LIBRARIES NOW ARE
TRYING TO MAKE THE SPACE INSIDE
OF THEM MORE FLEXIBLE.
LIBRARIES THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE
THAT PEOPLE TALK ABOUT LIBRARY
DIRECTORS IN THE LIBRARY USERS
IS CAN WE HAVE MORE PRIVATE
STUDY ROOMS FOR COLLABORATION
RIGHT SO THE LIBRARY OF THE
FUTURE IS A PLACE THAT THE
SILICATES. SKILL SETS IN THE
ACTIVITIES RIGHT THE POWER THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY ECONOMY
COLLABORATION RIGHT
COMMUNICATION. AND OLDER
STRUCTURED LIBRARIES ARE BUILT.
I MEAN I DON'T MEAN THIS MAINLY
BUT OUR BUILT MORE AS A BOOK
REPOSITORY MAN AS A LEARNING
CENTER RIGHT THE SECOND THING
IS LIBRARIES NOW AND THIS IS
BEEN REINFORCED AFTER A YEAR OF
THE PANDEMIC WHEN PHYSICAL
DOORS WERE CLOSED. LIBRARIES
NOW ARE OFFERING A MIX OF
DIGITAL AND IN PERSON SERVICE
SO AN INCREASED NUMBER OF
PEOPLE ARE ENTERING THE LIBRARY
THROUGH ITS DIGITAL DOORS NOW-
AS OPPOSED TO AS OPPOSED TO
PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC. BUT THAT
THAT'S BEEN AN INCREASING
PATTERN RIGHT JUST AS MORE
PEOPLE BECOME MORE DIGITALLY.
CONNECTED I MEAN THERE'S A
VARIETY OF STRUCTURAL. CHANGES
TO. YOU KNOW FACILITATE THE
CHANGING ROLE THAT LIBRARIES
ARE PLAYING IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES GOVERNOR NEWSOM
CALLED THEM THE HEART OF THEIR
COMMUNITIES IN IN HIS LIBRARY
PROCLAMATION. AND I THINK IN IN
MANY RESPECTS THAT ARE BECOMING
THEM- IF THEY ARE IF THEY
AREN'T ALREADY. I MIGHT I CAN
SEND YOU SOME MORE ON ON THIS
IS THAT IS THAT HELPING IT SO.
TO GET BACK TO YOUR QUESTION I
MEAN A BILLION DOLLARS HELPS
ADDRESS THE MOST. PRESSING
NEEDS BUT DOESN'T. HELP US FIX
USUALLY THAT'S NOT THAT'S NOT
RIGHT- IT HELPS ADDRESS THE
PRESSING NEEDS BUT A. B.
SUSTAINED INVESTMENT STRATEGY.
TO MODERNIZE AND GROW IT IN THE
CASES OF COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
THAT HAVE HAD A HUGE POPULATION
INCREASE OVER THE PAST FORTY
YEARS THE GIRL LIBRARY
FACILITIES. IS THE SORT OF
STRATEGY THAT'S NECESSARY TO
ACCOMPLISH WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT CENTER. I APPRECIATE THAT
ANSWER THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU. SENATOR TROUBLED GOOD
MORNING- AND THANK YOU TO-
EVERYONE HERE TODAY I DID HAVE
ONE QUESTION IN THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE PROVIDE THE
REMAINING DEBT SERVICE AMOUNT
IF ANY OF FOR THE E. NINETEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT AND THE TWO
THOUSAND GEO. BOND. JENNIFER
LEEWITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND THE ADMINISTRATION
DOES NOT HAVE ANY FORMAL
COMMENT ASSOCIATED WITH THE
SENATE'S PROPOSAL. THANK YOU.
SENATOR IF I MAY I THINK THAT
YOU'RE ASKING ABOUT AND
REMAINING PAYMENTS ON THAT
SERVICE IS THAT CORRECT YES. WE
REMEMBER. FOLLOW UP WITH YOUR
YEAH PERFECT THANK YOU GREAT
YEAH WE ITS REGULAR AT THE
LIBRARY WE DO WE MAY HAVE THAT
AS WELL- JUST YOU KNOW IN OUR
PAPERWORK CLOSE OUT ON THE-
CONSTRUCTION PROGRAM SO WE WILL
WORK WITH BRIANNA AND GET THAT
THE GRANT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS. THEN LET ME THANK
EVERYONE ON THE FIRST PANEL-
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO ISSUE
TO. UC AND CSU ENROLLMENT JASON
CONSTANT TOURISTS FROM THE
ALEJO'S OFFICE WILL BE BACK
SIEGE OF BURTON AND FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA RYAN
STORM FROM THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY.M. BRIAN RUTLEDGE
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND WILL GO IN THAT ORDER WILL
BEGIN WITH JASON CONSTANT TO
ACROSS. WHICH IS IN CONSTANT
TAURUS AGAIN LMAO. THIS ITEM
BEFORE YOU FOLKS IS- FOCUSES ON
ENROLLMENT AT UC AND CSU SO I'M
GOING TO BE ADDRESSING EACH
SEGMENT ONE OF THE TIME. FOR
YOU SEE THE SENATE DEMOCRATS
PLAN. CONNECTS RESIDENT WOMAN
GROWS TO A MULTI YEAR PLAN.
THAT SIMULTANEOUSLY REDUCES
NONRESIDENT ENROLLMENT. HOUSE
PAGE SEVEN OF YOUR AGENDA NOTES
YOU SEE CURRENTLY HAS A POLICY
IN PLACE TO LIMIT NONRESIDENTS
MOMENTS- GOOD POLICY
EFFECTIVELY. FOR MOST CAMPUSES-
LIMITS NON RESIDENT ROMAN AS A
SHARE OF- RESIDENT WILL HAVE A
TOUGH TOTAL ENROLLMENT I'M NOT
SURE IS BASICALLY LOCKED IN
PLACE FOR MOST CAMPUSES. BY
CONTRAST THIS PLAN THAT YOU'RE
HEARING ABOUT WOULD EFFECTIVELY
REDUCE THE SHARE FOR MOST
CAMPUSES SO IT IS A REDUCTION
IN ON REASONABLE AND RATHER
THAN JUST A LITTLE. PAGE I'M
NOT PAGE NINE OF YOUR AGENDA
PROVIDES- A SUMMARY- ARE IN AND
AN INITIAL SUMMARY OF THE OF
THE PLAN UNDER THE SENATE
SENATE DEMOCRATS BUDGET PLAN.
I'LL JUST WALK THROUGH IT
REALLY QUICKLY IF YOU START AT
THE- TOP OF THE TABLE YOU WILL
SEE THE EFFORTS SIX CAMPUSES.
OF THOSE CAMPUSES IT WOULD
REDUCE THE SHARE OF THEIR
FRIEND INCOMING FRESHMEN WHO
ARE NON RESIDENTS. HE 10% AND
THEY WOULD ACCOMPLISH THIS OVER
A ROUGHLY TEN YEAR PERIOD- THE
REMAINING THREE CAMPUSES THAT
HAVE SHARES THAT ARE ALREADY
BELOW 10% WOULD HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY TO INCREASE THEIR
SHARES TO THAT 10% ONE THAT.
I'M WHICH IS WHAT'S BEING
DISPLAYED HERE ON THE TABLE. IF
YOU MOVE TO THAT MIDDLE PART OF
THE TABLE. DISPLAYS THE NUMBER
OF FRESHMEN YOU'LL SEE THAT
THE- GROWTH IN THE RESIDENT
FRESHMAN IS SLIGHTLY LARGER
THAN THE GROWTH FOR THE
REDUCTION OF NON RESIDENT. I
THINK AND THAT'S BECAUSE OF THE
GROWTH IN NON RESIDENT MOMENT
OUT THOSE REMAINING THREE
CAMPUSES. AND WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH STAFF ON WHAT-
THIS PLAN MIGHT COST OUR
INITIAL ESTIMATE- GOING TOWARDS
THE BOTTOM OF THE- PEOPLE THERE
WOULD BE FIFTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS. IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET.
AND THAT WOULD BE BOTH TO- OR
COVERED THE LAST REVENUE
ASSOCIATED WITH REDUCING THE
NONRESIDENT MOMENT. AND ALSO TO
OTHER COSTS TO INCREASE
RESIDENT WILL MANAGE. YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THIS TABLE IT MIGHT
REYES- TWO QUESTIONS THE FIRST
QUESTION IT MIGHT RAISES WHY IS
YOUR ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE AND NOT THE BUDGET
YEAR WHICH IS TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. AND THE REASON FOR
THIS IS THAT UC HAS LARGELY
MADE ITS FALL ADMISSION
DECISIONS. FOR FALL TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. AND SO YOU SEE
LIKELY WOULD NEED AN ADDITIONAL
YEAR BEFORE CAN START
IMPLEMENTING ITS PLAN TO REDUCE
NON RESIDENT MOMENT. I ALSO
NOTE THAT THE STATE BUDGET IN
RECENT YEARS HAS TAKEN A
SIMILAR APPROACH IS PROVIDED AN
ENROLLMENT GROWTH FUNDING IN
THE BUDGET BUT THEN SET THE
TARGET FOR ONE YEAR LATER. FOR
THE EXACT SAME REASON YOU SEE
ALL HAS ALREADY MADE POLITICIAN
DECISIONS BY THE TIME THE
BUDGETS OVERSIGHT GIVEN THE
SIGNAL TO MAKE PLANS FOR THE
FOLLOWING YEAR. ON THE SECOND
QUESTION THAT THIS PLAN MIGHT
RAISE IS WHY IS THE RESIDENT.
COST LARGER THAN THE NON
RESIDENT COSTS. AT LEAST IN THE
FIRST YEAR AND THERE ARE A FEW
REASONS FOR THAT- ONE REASON IS
THAT OUR OUR ESTIMATES INCLUDE
SOME PROJECTIONS AND CONTINUING
ENROLLMENT RATHER THAN JUST NEW
ROMANCE AND THAT. INCREASES THE
GROWTH IN RESIDENT MOMENT IN
THE IN THE FIRST YEAR OF THE
PLAN. THIS IS BEING DRIVEN BY
THE POLICY BUT IT IS A GROWTH
THAT WE PROJECT YOU SEE MAY
ENCOUNTER AND IT'S A COST THAT
THE- LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER
AS PART OF ITS- FINAL BUDGET
DECISIONS. ALSO THAT RESIDENT
ROMAN NUMBER INCLUDES ON THE
COST OF THE CAL GRANT PROGRAMS
WHEN THE STATE INCREASES
RESIDENT MOMENT THAT YOU SEE.
NOT ONLY DOES IT INCREASE.
COSTS ASSOCIATED HIRING MORE
FACULTY AND STAFF. IT ALSO
INCREASED COST TO THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAMS FOR THE STUDENTS WHO
ARE LOW INCOME AND ON THE
CALDERON PROGRAM. SO THOSE
COSTS ARE INCLUDED IN THERE AS
WELL. ONE FINAL THING TO NOTE
IS THAT THIS IS A MULTI YEAR
PLAN SO EACH YEAR YOU SEE IS
CONTINUING TO INCREASE
RESIDENT. AND REDUCING NON
RESIDENT MOMENT AND SO EACH
YEAR THE COSTS ESCALATE WE
ESTIMATE THAT EVENTUALLY THE
ONGOING COSTS WOULD RISE TO
ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS NOT FOR
FINAL YEAR GLOBALIZATION. AND
THEIR AFTER THAT WOULD BE THE
ONGOING COSTS OF THE PROGRAM.
THAT'S THE YOU SEE- PLAN FOR
CSU THE PLAN IS A LITTLE
SIMPLER SO GO THROUGH A LOT
QUICKER. ON THE SENATE
DEMOCRATS PLAN AIMS TO INCREASE
SEE IF YOU RESIDENT MOMENT- BUT
WITHOUT A CORRESPONDING
REDUCTION IN NON RESIDENT WOMAN
AND THIS IS BECAUSE IT CSU
NONRESIDENT MOMENT IS ALREADY.
LESS THAN 10% OF TOTAL
UNDERGRADUATE ENROLLMENT. I'M
HERE STAFF INDICATES THAT THE
ENROLLMENT TARGET FOR CSU HAS
NOT BEEN FINALIZED ON THIS WILL
BE SOMETHING THAT WILL BE
FINALIZED. AFTER THE REVISION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND NOW WILL MOVE TO US TO
JUDGE BURTON AND FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. I
THINK YOU CHIRLA HEARD AND
MEMBERS I'M SAY EVER CANNON
REPRESENTING THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. WHICH THE GOAL OF
INCREASING THE AMOUNT OF
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE GRADUATES.
IT'S APPROVED THE FRAMEWORK
TWENTY THIRTY PLAN WITH THE
INTENT OF INCREASING THE NUMBER
IF YOU SEE DECREASED BY CLOSING
GRADUATION GAPS FOR LOW INCOME
AND UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS
BY TWENTY THIRTY. TWENTY THIRTY
INCREASES THE ACCESS FOR
CALIFORNIA UNDERGRADUATES
BECAUSE WHEN STUDENTS GRADUATE
IN A TIMELY MATTER UNIVERSITY
CAN ADMIT MORE STUDENTS FOR THE
FOLLOWING CLASS. YOU SEE
REQUEST THAT YOU PROVIDE
ONGOING FUNDING FOR OUR CAMPUS
IS TO CLOSE GRADUATION GAPS AS
PART OF YOUR STRATEGY FOR MORE
UC INVOLVEMENT. UC'S ABILITY TO
ENROLL MORE STUDENTS IS
DEPENDENT ON STATE SUPPORT IN
TWENTY NINETEEN THE LEGISLATURE
PROVIDES. WITH TWO YEARS OF
ENROLLMENT GROWTH SPENDING THAT
A LOT OF YOU SEE TOMORROW NOT
JUST OUR LARGEST EVER INCOMING
UNDERGRADUATE CLASS. ARE
DISCUSSED EVER OF UNDER.
MINORITY STUDENTS. YOU SEE ALSO
ENROLLS MORE LOW INCOME
STUDENTS THAN ANY OTHER
RESEARCH UNIVERSITY SYSTEM IN
THE COUNTRY. IT IS STATES
ROBUST CAL GRANT PROGRAMS AND
UC'S INSTITUTIONAL FINANCIAL
AID THAT MAKES IT POSSIBLE 456%
OF OUR CALIFORNIA
UNDERGRADUATES. TUITION AND
FEES FULLY COVERED. SINCE
TWENTY FIFTEEN YOU SEE HAS
INCREASED CALIFORNIA
UNDERGRADUATE ENROLLMENT BY
NINETEEN THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
STUDENTS. PROVIDED YOU SEE
WITHIN ROMAN TARGETS AND
FUNDING FOR FOURTEEN THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY OF THOSE
STUDENTS LEAVING THE UNIVERSITY
TO COVER THE COST OF EDUCATION
FOR THE REMAINING FIVE THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED. CITY ENSURES
HIGH QUALITY EDUCATION FOR
THESE UNFUNDED CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS STUDENTS AND PART.
AVENUE COLLECTED FROM OUR NON
RESIDENT STUDENTS. OKAY A
SUPPLEMENTAL TUITION IN
ADDITION THE MANDATORY TUITION
AND FEES THAT ALL STUDENTS ARE
CHARGED. CURRENTLY THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
RECEIVED OVER 14% OF OUR CAMPUS
OR FUNDS FOR NONRESIDENT
SUPPLEMENTAL TUITION PAID BY
NON RESIDENT STUDENTS. IT OPENS
ARE SPENT ON MANY ASPECTS OF
THE CAMPUS OPERATIONS FROM
HIRING FACULTY TO OFFER MORE
COURSES THE STUDENT SERVICES
AND FINANCIAL AID FOR RESIDENT
STUDENTS MAINTAINING CAMPUS
FACILITIES. NONRESIDENT THE
REVENUE IS AN ONGOING FUNDING
SOURCE THAT THE UC REGENTS CAN
INCREASE EVERY YEAR REFLECTING
THIS REVENUE SOURCE WITH A
FIXED ALLOCATION OF STATE
GENERAL FUND WOULD LIMIT THE
UNIVERSITY'S ABILITY TO RESPOND
TO INFLATIONARY COST PRESSURES.
AND CREATE A FINANCIAL LONGER
ABILITY IN THE FUTURE
RECESSION. INSTEAD OF REMOVING
A GROUP OF STUDENTS UNIVERSITY
REQUEST THAT THE LEGISLATURE
INSTEAD PROVIDE FUNDS TO ENROLL
MORE CALIFORNIA UNDERGRADUATES.
WOULD PREFERRED THAT THE
LEGISLATURE PRE FUNDED MOMENT
NOW NOT JUST FOR FALL TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUT FOR FALL TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AS WELL SO THAT THE
UNIVERSITY CAN ADEQUATELY PLAN
FOR DEER ARRIVAL OF THE NEW
CALL WORK. WE REQUESTED ANY NEW
CALIFORNIA UNDERGRADUATE
ENROLLMENT BE FUNDED AT THE
FULL MARGINAL COST OF
INSTRUCTION. INCREASING
CALIFORNIA UNDERGRADUATES DRUG
BUDGET ALLOCATION WITH AN
ENROLLMENT TARGET IS ALSO FAR
LESS EXPENSIVE FOR THE STATE
AND A BUYOUT PROGRAM OF NON
RESIDENT STUDENTS. ENROLLMENT
TARGET THE LEGISLATURE CAN
DIRECT UNIVERSITY TO INVOLVE
MORE STUDENTS THAT WOULD BE
FEASIBLE UNDER THE NON RESIDENT
STUDENT REPLACEMENT PLAN
OUTLINED IN YOUR AGENDA.
ONGOING ENROLLMENT FUNDING
WOULD ALLOW THE UNIVERSITY TO
COMPETENTLY HIGHER FACULTIES
PROVIDE INSTRUCTION WITHOUT THE
CONCERNS OF REPLACING ANOTHER
ON GOING REVENUE SOURCE
TOGETHER WE CAN ENSURE ACCESS
AND SUCCESS FOR CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS AND I'M AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF RYAN STORM FROM
CSU. WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE.
IN ODER SENATOR SIGNED STILL
IS JUST VICE FOR THE- STATE
UNIVERSITY CHANCELLOR OFFICE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR- TO. THE
COMMITTEE TODAY. SO KEEPING
COMMENTS BRIEF ALL FOCUSED ON
TWO MAJOR THEMES THE FIRST IS A
SUMMARY OF ENROLLMENT AT THE C.
ISSUE. AND THE SECOND IS OUR
COMMENTARY AS YOU CONSIDER
GROWING ENROLLMENT AT THE
UNIVERSITY. SO SINCE THE END OF
THE GREAT RECESSION THE STATE
AND THE SPEECH YOU HAVE ADDED
FORTY ONE THOUSAND NEW FUNDED
SEATS AT THE C. ISSUE. TODAY
pSTUDENTS IN ITS HISTORY THAT IS
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX
THOUSAND STUDENTS. SYSTEM WIDE
WE ARE ABOUT 5% OVER ARE FUNDED
ENROLLMENT LEVELS. ENROLLMENT
IS VERY STRONG IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. IN ROLE THAT HAS NOT
BEEN A STRONG IN OUR NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA CAMPUSES RECENTLY.
OUR SYSTEM WHY THE CROWN OF
VIRUS DID NOT IMPACT OUR
ENROLLMENT LEVELS THIS ACADEMIC
YEAR. IN THE VAST MAJORITY OF
PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS ARE
ADMITTED TO THEIR LOCAL CAMPUS.
THERE IS STRONG DEMAND AT OUR
FULLER TEN SO SAN DIEGO AND SAN
LUIS OBISPO CAMPUS SINCE AND
EVEN AT THOSE CAMPUSES STRONG
MAJORITIES OF LOCAL STUDENTS
ARE ADMITTED. IT MISTER
PRIORITY IS GIVEN TO LOCAL
STUDENTS AT EVERY ISSUE CAMPUS.
NOW NOT EVERYONE WHO IS.
ELIGIBLE SUBMITTED TO THEIR
FIRST CHOICE CAMPUS. THAT IS
SIMPLY THE ECONOMICS OF DEMAND
EXCEEDING SUPPLY. TELL US YOUR
PERSPECTIVE STUDENTS HAVE
ADDITIONAL OPTIONS FOR A
SEIZURE EDUCATION. THE
UNIVERSITY HAS FOR THREE FALL
ADMISSIONS CYCLES IMPLEMENTED A
REDIRECTION POLICY THAT
PROVIDES ALL PROSPECTIVE
STUDENTS AMPLE OPPORTUNITIES TO
ATTEND THE SECOND OR THIRD
CHOICE CAMPUS. NO WE DON'T JUST
OFFER STUDENT ACCESS THEY
GRADUATE. INTO SEVENTH GRADER
RATES EACH YEAR. AND I AM
PLEASED TO CONTINUE TO REPORT
THEIR GRADUATION RATES CONTINUE
ON THIS UPWARD TRAJECTORY IN
EVERY CATEGORY. LAST YEAR.
HUNDRED TWENTY NINE THOUSAND
STUDENTS EARN THEIR DEGREES IN
THE CSU. THAT'S A SUMMARY OF
OUR ROLE THAT CSU. NOW TOTALING
GROSS AND ARE UNSOLICITED
FEEDBACK AS YOU CONSIDER
FUNDING ADDITIONAL SEATS AT THE
UNIVERSITY. THE SENATE'S BILL
BACK ALL THE PLANS SIX DEGREES
ROMAN AT THE CSU THERE ARE
SEVERAL CONDITIONS THOUGH THAT
MUST BE MET FOR THIS TO BE
SUCCESSFUL AT THE CSU. FIRST IT
IS SEIZE HIS POSITION TO SEE
ISSUES GRADUATION ISSUE OF
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE MUST FIRST
BE FULLY FUNDED WITH SIXTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONGOING
SUNDAY. A FULLY FUNDED
INITIATIVE WILL HELP US REACH
OUR GOAL OF ELIMINATING EQUITY
GAPS FOR CURRENT STUDENTS AND
THEY ARE OUR FIRST PRIORITY.
ONLY AFTER THAT UNIVERSITY
PRIORITY IS FUNDED DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE TO CONSIDER THE
DISCRETIONARY CHOICE OF ADDING
MORE PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS TO
THE CSU. SECOND ENROLLMENT
TRAINING MUST BE ONGOING IT
CANNOT BE ONE. TIME OR ONE TIME
FUNDING CANNOT SUSTAIN MORE
PERMANENT FACULTY AND STAFF
NEEDED TO EDUCATE STUDENTS.
THIRD THE STATE'S SHARE NEW
ROLLING COSTS WOULD BE EIGHT
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS
PER FULL TIME EQUIVALENT
STUDENT. THAT'S LIKE- MR TIME
AND WAS TALKING ABOUT THAT'S
THE FULL MARGINAL COST OF
EDUCATING STUDENTS WITH THIS
ISSUE. SO IN OTHER WORDS IF YOU
PROVIDED EIGHT POINT SIX
MILLION IN ONGOING FUNDING TO
THE UNIVERSITY WE CAN EDUCATE
ABOUT A THOUSAND MORE STUDENTS.
A FOURTH IN ROMAN TARGETS MUST
BE SAID IT FUNDED LEVELS. IF
THE SENATE WERE TO INCLUDE AN
ENROLLMENT TARGET IN THE BUDGET
THE STARTING POINT IS. THREE
HUNDRED SEVENTY FOUR THOUSAND
ONE HUNDRED THIRTY ONE FULL
TIME EQUIVALENT STUDENTS. SIXTY
YEARS THE STATE AND THE
UNIVERSITYHAVE METICULOUSLY
ADDED NEW FUNDING AND NEW
STUDENT A QUIBBLE AND
EXPECTATIONS TO ARRIVE AT THAT
CURRENT NUMBER. THAT'S A
DECADES OLD CONTRACT THAT WE
HAVE SO TO SPEAK TO EDUCATE
THAT THAT NUMBER OF STUDENTS.
IF YOU WERE TO CHOOSE TO
GROWING ROLE THAT WOULD PROVIDE
THE FUNDING AND GROW THE
ENROLLMENT TARGET. NOW FIFTH
AND LASTLY C. ISSUES POSITION
IS THAT MEETING A NEW TARGET
SHOULD BE EXPECTED IN THE
SECOND COLLEGE YEAR AND NOT THE
FIRST. MISTER CONSTANT TAURUS
AND THIS FOR TEN AND MENTIONED
THAT ISSUE AS WELL. PRACTICALLY
THAT WOULD BE MEETING TARGET AT
THE CONCLUSION OF THE TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE COLLEGE YEAR
AND NOT THIS UPCOMING. ACADEMIC
YEAR THE REASON FOR THIS IS
THAT ALL IN A CAMPUS ADMISSION
DECISIONS IN GENERAL THAT
DECISIONS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
MADE. FOR THAT TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO YEAR OUR FIRST DAY
CLASSES TYPICALLY IS AROUND THE
THIRD WEEK OF AUGUST SO THERE'S
REALLY NO TIME TO ADD. MORE
STAFF OR STUDENTS AT THIS
POINT. IF YOU WERE TO GROWING
ONLY. TO HELP YOU FIND A
TESTIMONY HELPFUL AS YOU MAKE
THOSE FINAL DECISIONS ON SEIZE
YOUR MOMENT. MY COLLEAGUE DR
EQUAL CARRILLO THE DIRECTOR OF
ENROLLMENT MANAGEMENT SERVICES
AT THE CSU CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
IS HERE ALSO. TODAY TO
ANSWERING YOUR QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY AND OUR LAST AMONG
THE INITIAL PRESENTATION SAYS
BRIAN RUTLEDGE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. WELCOME
TO THE COMMITTEE. THE MORNING
CARE MEMBERS BRIAN RUTLEDGE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I'M HAPPY
TO TAKE QUESTIONS ON THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR
UC'S CSU. AND THE EARLY ACTION
FROM FEBRUARY. THANK YOU OKAY
WISH YOU COULD TAKE A QUESTIONS
ON HIS MAY REVISED BUT- RIGHT
WHERE WE GET THE WHAT'S GOING
ON LT ME BEGIN WITH SOME
QUESTIONS AND I WOULD LIKE TO.
THE FOCUS FIRST AT SIERRA OF
VIRGIN AND ARE WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. AND
IN YOUR PRESENTATION YOU LISTED
ALL THE FACTORS. OF THAT MIGHT
AFFECT YOUR ABILITY TO INCREASE
ENROLLMENT OR MOVE PEOPLE
THROUGH. UP BUT YOU DID NOT
ADDRESS THE SUBJECT OF
FACILITIES IT SEEMS THAT YOUR
COMMENTS WERE BASED ON- JUST
MAXIMIZING CURRENT FACILITIES.
R. A. N. DEFENDER STARTING TO
BUMP UP AGAINST THE DEMAND OF
NOT BEING IS YOU SEE HAVE A
PLAN IN ANY WAY TO INCREASE
FACILITIES AND THEREFORE
INCREASE THE ABILITY TO- ARE AT
ENROLLMENT. THANK YOU SIR
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA DID
SEND- THE GOVERNOR AIM NAY
REVISED PROPOSAL REQUESTING ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS PER
FACILITIES CONSTRUCTION
INCLUDING SEISMIC RENOVATIONS
AND- IT CLASSROOM MODERNIZATION
PROJECTS BUT WE DO ALSO HAVE
OUR CAMPUS LONG RANGE
DEVELOPMENT PLANS. WHICH PLAN
WORKS SERVICE GUIDELINES OR
INCREASING ENROLLMENT AND
ACADEMIC PLANNING OF BY CALLING
FOR THE CONSTRUCTION OF CERTAIN
BUILDINGS ON THE CAMPUS SAYS
BUT THERE DEFINITELY IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE UNIVERSITY
TO CONSTRUCT NEW FACILITIES IN
ORDER TO EXPAND ENROLLMENT. WE
DO BELIEVE WEST- OUR EXISTING
FACILITIES AND WITH THE HELP OF
EXPANDED SUMMER ESPECIALLY IN
ON THE INSTRUCTIONS THAT THERE
MAY BE ABILITY FOR THE
UNIVERSITY TO GROW UP AT ITS
PRESENT PHYSICAL CAPACITY AS
WELL. AND AS YOU MENTIONED THE
REQUEST OF. TO THE GOVERNOR FOR
MARY THAT SUBSTANTIALLY
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE WILL THE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL ROOM FOR STUDENTS
ORSETT DEFERRED MAINTENANCE TO
JUST MAINTAIN. THE CAPACITY FOR
EXISTING LEVELS OF ENROLLMENT.
OUR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
REQUEST- MAINTAINS THE EXISTING
CAPACITY BARN ROLE WITH- AND
WHAT WE DO HAVE- SOME PLANS FOR
NEW CONSTRUCTION AS WELL AND
RENOVATION OF BUILDINGS IT'S
REALLY THE BUILDING RENOVATION
THAT WILL ALLOW US TO EXPAND
CAPACITY BECAUSE MANY OF OUR
OLDER CAMPUSES HAVE CLASSROOM
CAPACITY THAT. DOESN'T REALLY
SUPPORT THE MODERN PEDAGOGY
ESPECIALLY IN SCIENCES AND
SCIENCE LABS AND SOME OF THOSE
CLASSROOMS ARE GOING UNDER
UTILIZED IF THEY COULD BE
RENOVATED WE COULD HAVE MORE
COURSES ARE MOVING THROUGH
THOSE CLASSROOM FACILITIES. BUT
IT IS WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
OVERALL THAT THE LONG RANGE
DEVELOPMENT PLANS WHICH HAD.
OUR OUR CAPACITY WITH
ADDITIONAL BUILDINGS AND SOME
CAMPUSES AND THE EXPANDED
SUMMER OPPORTUNITIES AND THE
RENOVATIONS WHICH MIGHT
INCREASE CAPACITY BECAUSE OF
MODERNIZATION. WOULD ACTUALLY
MEET THE DEMAND OR ARE YOU
SUGGESTING THAT THAT WOULD MEET
THE DEMAND TO THE CALIFORNIANS
HAVE TO COME INTO THE UC SYSTEM.
I THINK IT DEPENDS ON HOW
SERVER YOU ARE DEFINING MEETING
THE DEMAND CURRENTLY THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA ADMITS
ABOUT 13% OF CALIFORNIA HIGH
SCHOOL. GRADUATES INTO- OUR
SYSTEM NOT ALL OF THOSE
STUDENTS END UP ENROLLING-
ORDING TO THE MASTER PLAN YOU
SEE IS MEETING THAT DEMAND.
FORCE IN ADMITTING THIRD
HIGHEST- ARE GRADE LEVELS ARE
HIGHEST QUALIFYING CALIFORNIA
BASICALLY THE PERCENTAGE THAT.
THAT IS SPELLED OUT IN THE
MASTER PLAN FOR YOU SEE YOU
BELIEVE THIS MAT WITH BUDGET
REQUESTS THAT ARE CURRENTLY ON
THE TABLE. IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING. I'M SAYING THAT
CURRENTLY UC ADMITS- NO I KNOW
YOU'RE GIVEN ME THE NUMBERS BUT
I'M TRYING TO DO THEY'RE SORT
OF A PERCENTAGE DEMANDED SLIDE
OUT INTO IN THE MASTER PLAN AND
I'M JUST TRYING TO SEE IF WHAT
YOUR PLANS TO ADMIT MATCH THE
PERCENTAGE IN THE MASTER PLAN.
CURRENTLY WE ARE PLANNING ON
AND- HOLDING IN ROMAN FLAG
FOOTBALL TWENTY TWENTY ONE
UNLESS WE RECEIVE NEW.
ENROLLMENT FUNDING FROM THE
LEGISLATURE- BUT THAT
ENROLLMENT LEVEL WOULD ALLOW US
TO MEET THE MASTERPLAN
PERCENTAGE. ABOUT WE HEAR THAT
THE LEGISLATURE DEFINITELY
WANTS TO INCREASE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOLERS
WANTING TO GET INTO THE UC
SYSTEM. AND WE THINK WE CAN
WORK WITH YOU. AS LONG AS WE
RECEIVE ADEQUATE FUNDING FOR
THE MARGINAL COST OF
INSTRUCTION TO HIRE NEW
INSTRUCTORS WE THINK WE CAN
ACCOMMODATE MORE PASSED A MORE
HIGH SCHOOLERS COMING IN S.
CALIFORNIA FRESHMAN TO THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA SYSTEM-
THIS FALL EVEN. IF WE WERE TO
RECEIVE THE FUNDING TO HIRE
FACULTY. OKAY WELL. ARE
ANSWERED I THINK ONE OF THE SUB
TAX ONE OF THE SUB TAX- FOR ME
IS REPRESENTING- UC CAMPUS IN
MY DISTRICT WITH THE LATEST
LONG RANGE DEVELOPMENT PLAN
SHOWS THEM GOING TO A MAXIMUM
THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE FEEL IS
NOT SUSTAINABLE IN TERMS OF THE
IMPACTS THAT ARE CREATED I'M
TRYING TO LOOK IF MEETING THE
MASTER PLAN NEEDS. FALLS ON
THAT OR BUILDING OUT AT MERCED
REQUIRING MILLS COLLEGE OTHER
THINGS MIGHT ACTUALLY PROVIDE
THE GROWTH THAT CHORE
ANTICIPATING FOR THE SENATE AND
I'VE SAID THIS BEFORE THE I
KNOW THE UNIVERSITY HAS DELAYED
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS OVER THE
CITING AND THE CONSTRUCTION OF
THE UC MERCED CAMPUS I AM JUST
WONDERING AND MAYBE THE
POSSIBILITY OF MILLS COLLEGE
TAKES THAT OFF THE TABLE
WHETHER WE NEED TO BE LOOKING
AT ADDITIONAL CENTERS OR
FACILITIES TO ACCOMMODATE THE
GROWTH OVER TIME WHEN I HAD THE
YEAR TO YEAR. ANSWER I KNOW
THAT'S IN FRONT OF US WITH
REGARD TO THIS BUDGET BUT IF I
AM HERE FOR FOUR YEARS OR EIGHT
YEARS THEY'LL BE FUTURE BUDGETS
WHERE PEOPLE ASK VOTED PEOPLE
PLAN FOR THIS EVENTUALITY WILL
THIS IS THE TIME YOU PLANNED
FOR THIS IS THE TIME TO TALK
ABOUT IT AND WHEN THIS THE SUN
IS SHINING ECONOMICALLY ON THE
BUDGET THOSE ARE THE TIMES TO
SORT OF DEAL WITH THAT SO
THAT'S- WHAT I WAS A DRIVING AT
IN AND I THINK OUR EXCHANGES
MADE THE POINTS BUT IT IT. DID
HI I JUST WANNA PUT THAT OUT
THERE IS AN ISSUE THE OTHER
THING I WANTED TO ASK ABOUT AND.
ASK THE UC REPRESENTATIVE. IS
ABOVE YOU. ON THE NOTION OF OUT
OF STATE TUITION OUT OF STATE
STUDENTS AND MEN THAT PERCENT.
AND YOU TALKED ABOUT ALL THE
THINGS THAT YOU HOPE THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD DO OTHER THAN
THE PROPOSAL THAT'S IN FRONT OF
US TO ACCOMMODATED. AND I
DIDN'T UNDERSTAND CLEARLY WHAT
THE UNIVERSITY WHAT YOU SEE WAS
FOR WITH REGARD TO OUT OF STATE
STUDENTS YOU NAMED ALL THE
ALTERNATIVES- FOR. BUT OVER
TIME IS YOU SEE IN FAVOR OF
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF OUT OF
STATE STUDENTS I DIDN'T GET
THAT FROM YOUR TESTIMONY. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTIONS ARE WE
ARE NOT IN FAVOR OF REDUCING
OUR OUT OF STATE. STUDENTS MORE
THAN THE REGION'S TOP SO WE
WANT TO MAINTAIN THE TOP ON NON
RESIDENT STUDENTS. ADOPTED BY
THE UC REGENTS IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WE THINK THAT- HELPS
THE UNIVERSITY MAINTAIN. OUR
REVENUE SOURCES AND ALSO.
ALLOWS A STATEMENT ARE
CONTINUALLY MORE CALIFORNIA.
RESIDENT UNDERGRADUATES INTO
OUR SYSTEM HOW TO IS LEAVING
THE NUMBER HIVE OUT OF STATE
STUDENTS ALLOW YOU TO ADMIT
MORE IN STATE STUDENTS. BECAUSE
CURRENTLY ARE OUT OF STATE
STUDENTS HE AB. TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND DOLLAR ADDITIONAL FEE.
ALLOWS US TO HAVE THE REVENUE
TO HIRE MORE INSTRUCTORS STAND
BY THE CAMPUS OPERATIONS- OUR
STATE FUNDING PER STUDENT HAS-
DESPITE THE FACT THAT YOU'VE
BEEN INCREASING. STATE FUNDING
FOR THE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM ARE
WE HAVE COST EXPENDITURES HAVE
GROWN SO MUCH AND WE'VE TAKEN
ON NEW ENROLLMENT- THAT ARE
DOLLARS PER STUDENT HAS
ACTUALLY BEEN FALLING BUT WE
CAN SPEND SO RESTRICTING DOC
NONRESIDENT SUPPLEMENTAL
TUITION REVENUE SOURCE WOULD
MEAN THAT IN A CASE OF A
RECESSION WE WILL HAVE LESS
MONEY TO FALL BACK ON IT'S
ANOTHER QUESTION FOR THE
UNIVERSITY TO ENSURE THAT WE
CAN MAINTAIN QUALITY DIFFICULT.
FINANCIAL TIMES. AND SO THIS
THIS TIES TOGETHER DIRECTLY
WITH THE FIRST SET OF QUESTIONS
I WAS ASKING BECAUSE IF. IT
SEEMS THAT THE CONTENTION IS
THAT HAVING OUT OF STATE
STUDENTS AT THE LEVEL THAT IT
IS NOW IS NOT IN ANY WAY
DISADVANTAGING OR CAUSING IN
STATE STUDENTS TO BE TURNED
AWAY FROM ADMISSIONS IS THAT
WHAT I'M UNDERSTANDING. THAT IS
CORRECT SIR- IN FACT AT THE
MOMENT UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
HAS OVER FIVE THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT
UNDERGRADUATES ENROLLED FOR
HOME WE'VE NOT RECEIVED THE
STATE OF MARGINAL COST OF
INSTRUCTION SHARE. AND IF WE
START REDUCING OUR NON RESIDENT
POPULATION WHO ARE CURRENTLY
PAYING FOR THOSE STUDENTS- IT
DOES REDUCE THE QUALITY OF
INSTRUCTION FOR THE STUDENTS
OBVIOUSLY WE WOULD NEVER KICK
OUT. A CALIFORNIA RESIDENT
STUDENT UP BUT WE DO HAVE TO
LOOK AT MAINTAINING THE QUALITY
IN OUR INSTITUTIONS AND YOU SEE
QUALITY SEEMS TO BE CORRELATED
WITH HIGH MONEY COMING FROM OUT
OF STATE AND I DO THINK THAT.
THAT THE PROPOSAL THAT'S IN
FRONT OF US BACK FEELS THAT
MONEY AND THE IDEA IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE MEETING THE
NEEDS OF ALL THE IN STATE
STUDENTS AND- AND DESPITE THE
FACT THAT IT. THE STATEMENT WAS
MADE THAT THE MASTER PLAN
PERCENTAGES MATT I JUST GET SO
MANY CALLS FROM PARENTS TO FEEL
LIKE THEIR KIDS ARE GETTING
INTO UC AND SO I THINK THAT IS
A GENUINE CONCERN. FROM THE
COMMITTEE AND I DO SUBSCRIBE TO
THE PROPOSAL AS A WAY OF MAKING
SURE THAT YOU SEE DOESN'T SEE
THIS AS AN ECONOMIC ISSUE BUT-
EQUITY ISSUE FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING IN THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA SYSTEM. I'M SURE
WE'LL HAVE MORE ANIMATED DEBATE
LET ME ASK IF THERE ARE ANY
COMMENTS WELL THERE IS A HAND
FROM THE PERSON I WAS GONNA ASK
IF YOU HAD A COMMENT- DOES THE.
L. A- WISH TO COMMENT ON THIS.
YEAH THOUGHT IT MIGHT HELP-
JUST PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION TO THE DISCUSSION-
JUST HAD- AND WE DID LOOK AT-
THAT'S YOUR FIRST QUESTION ON
LOOKING AT DEMAND AND CAPACITY
AT UC. AS WELL SEE THIS YEAR WE
DID LOOK AT THAT A FEW YEARS
AGO IN A REPORT- AND I ACTUALLY
JUST SAW IT JUST ON THE DEMAND
POINT I THINK ONE THING JUST TO
JUST TO. SHARPEN KEEP IN MIND
AS YOU SAID YOU'RE THINKING
ABOUT THIS. IS THAT- YOU SEE
HAS HISTORICALLY BAD THE MASTER
PLAN- TWELVE AND A HALF PERCENT
ELIGIBILITY FULL- BUT IN RECENT
YEARS THEY'VE HAD TO
INCREASINGLY- REFER STUDENTS
TO- CAMPUSES LIKE RIVER CITING
MERCED. CAMPUS IS THAT MAY BE
WORTH THEIR FIRST CHOICE OR
THAT THEY DIDN'T NECESSARILY
APPLY TO. AND A LOT OF THE
STUDENTS END UP CHOOSING NOT TO
ENROLL YOU SEE- AND SO ONE OF
THE- KEY ISSUES FOR THE
LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN- NOT JUST
EXPANDING ACCESS SYSTEM WIDE
BUT CONTINUING TO SPEND EXPAND
ACCESS OF THESE HIGHER DEMAND
CAMPUSES LIKE BERKELEY AND UCLA
AND SAN DIEGO. AND IF YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT- OPTIONS TO
EXPAND WILL THAT. ON THAT WOULD
BE ONE THING TO KEEP IN MIND
THAT THE NON RESIDENT PLAN THAT
YOU'RE CONSIDERING-
SPECIFICALLY LOOKS AT EVERY
CAMPUS AND PRESUMABLY ONE OF
THE REASONS FOR THAT IS- THAT
IT IS TARGETING THESE HIGHER
DEMAND CAMPUSES THAT HAVE
THESE. HIGHER SHARES
NONRESIDENT STUDENTS- YOU DON'T
IN TERMS OF CAPACITY AGAIN-
JUST IT JUST IT PROVIDE A LOT
MORE INFORMATION THEIR- COMMON
WE LOOK AT CAPACITY ISSUES
WHICH WE DO SEE SOME-
ADDITIONAL CAPACITY AT SOME OF
THESE ARE HIGH DEMAND CAMPUSES
FOR INSTRUCTIONAL SPACES- BUT
AS- A SINGER REFERRED TO- A LOT
OF THE SPACES ARE- CLASSROOMS
THAT ARE- THEY'RE THEY'RE LIKE
SMALLER CLASSROOMS ARE NOT
NECESSARILY CAN FIGURE TO THE
WAY THEY DELIVER INSTRUCTION
TODAY THAT'S WHY WHEN SHE WAS
REFERRING TO THE RENOVATION OF
FACILITIES THAT THAT COULD BE
ONE WAY. TO IMPROVE THE
UTILIZATION OF THOSE FACILITIES
IS BY RECONFIGURING MOM- AS YOU
AS IT WAS ALSO NOTED THAT
SEGMENTS ALSO- COULD EXPAND
SUMMER MOMENT MORE THAN IT DOES
ANOTHER WAY ON THAT DATE STATUS
HISTORICALLY TRYING TO EXPAND-
ENROLLMENT WITHOUT AN
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
FACILITIES. I WOULD ALSO THERE
IS THE ISSUE THAT WAS RAISED
ABOUT LONG RANGE DEVELOP PLANS
AND THE IMPACT ON THE COMMUNITY
OKAY THIS IS A TOLD US EVEN IF
THEY DO HAVE UNDER UTILIZED
FACILITIES SOMETIMES THEY FACE
SOME EXTERNAL CONSTRAINTS. ALL
LIKE THEIR LONG RANGE
DEVELOPMENT PLANS CONNECT- AND
ROMAN GROWTH JOB INCREASES IN
HOUSING SO THAT DOES CREATE AT
LEAST IN THE SHORT TERM SOME
SOME CONSTRAINTS ON THEIR
ABILITY TO. MEET YOUR TO YOUR
INVOLVEMENT EXPECTATIONS AND SO
THAT'S JUST ANOTHER THING TO
CONSIDER TOO IF YOU'RE THINKING
ABOUT HOW MUCH CAPACITY RULES.
I JUST HOPE THAT HOPEFULLY IN
FOR. PROVIDES A LITTLE IT DOES
AND IT AND I DO HAVE A HAND
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
BEFORE I RECOGNIZE HIM I FEEL
OBLIGATED TO MAKE A COMMENT
ABOUT SOMETHING YOU DID AT THE
BEGINNING. AND IT'S- JUST I
DON'T WANT SILENCE TO SORT OF-
IT HERE THAT. MMHM RIVERSIDE
AND PARTICULARLY MERCED OR
INFERIOR CAMPUSES IN SOME WAY.
AND MERCED IN PARTICULAR. HAS
GONE FROM ZERO TO SIXTY IN
PROVIDING EXCELLENT EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES EVEN THOUGH. WE
PROBABLY SHOULD FUNDED SO IT'S
NOT A HUNDRED AND NINE EVERY
TIME SOMEBODY SITS OUTSIDE OR
TO GRADUATION A BECAUSE THERE'S
NOT IT'S AN INTERIOR BUILDING
TO DO THAT. BUT OUR OUR OUR I
WANT TO SPEAK FOR THOSE
CAMPUSES AND IN TERMS OF THE
EXCELLENCE OF THE EDUCATION
MISDIRECT WATTAGE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
TEACHER LEARNED I JUST WANTED
TO NOTE THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
SHARES THE CONCERNS YOU'RE
RAISING THE QUESTIONS. THEY'RE
ALSO THINKING ABOUT THAT THE
THERE'S TWO INVESTMENTS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THAT ARE
RELEVANT FOR CAPACITY FOR BOTH
UC AND CSU. BUT THE FIRST IS
THAT WERE. PROPOSING GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET 3% BASED AUGMENTATION
THAT'S A HUNDRED AND THREE
POINT NINE MILLION FOR YOU SEE
AND HUNDRED ELEVEN POINT FIVE
MILLION FOR CSU. ATTACHED TO
THAT IS AN EXPECTATION THAT ARE
BOTH SEGMENTS WILL ADOPT
POLICIES WHERE THEY HAVE TEN
PERCENTAGE POINTS MORE ONLINE
OFFERINGS THAN PRE COVE IT.
WHAT THAT'S PRIMARILY AIMED AT
AND STUDENT ACCESS BUT AT AN
INSTITUTIONAL LEVEL WHAT ONLINE
CAPACITY DOES IS IT DOES TAKE
SOME PRESSURE OFF INSTABILITIES
POTENTIALLY SO I WANTED A FLAG
THAT. I ALSO WANTED A FLAG THAT
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES A
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
ONE TIME FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE. FOR YOU SEE AND
THEN AN ADDITIONAL HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION. ONE TIME
FOR CSU AND SO THOSE ARE ALSO
FACILITIES CAPACITY AND SO I
JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT. I
APPRECIATE THAT- NOT BEEN
VISITED BY BOTH BRANCHES TO
THEN SAY THE NEXT THREE OR FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION THEY WOULD
REALLY LIKE TO SEE AS WELL
TERMS AND FOR MAINTENANCE SO.
JUST FOR THE RECORD OUT TO
SHORT CIRCUIT COMMENTS THAT ARE
OTHERWISE ABOUT TO COME. UP ARE
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ON THIS. FIVE FOLLOW UP
ON TO. ASK FOR- SENATOR MINUTES
OF FOLLOW UPS OF AHEAD AND THEN
IF CENTER GROW TROUBLE BECAUSE
OF. OR RECOGNIZE I MAY THIS AND-
BUT- ACCORDING TO. KELLY REPORT
WE HAVE- IT APPEARS WE'RE
LOOKING TO ALLOCATE FIFTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING. TO
COVER THE COSTS- THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR. A NEW FRESHMAN
ENROLLMENT AND TWENTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS TO REPLACE THE
REVENUE THAT UC'S WOULD HAVE
RECEIVED FROM. NON RESIDENT
STUDENTS. ARE MAYBE I MISSED
THIS BUT IT TO THE UC
REPRESENTATIVE ARE YOU SAYING
THAT THIS IS NOT ENOUGH TO
COVER. YOUR COSTS OF THE
DECREASED REVENUES. YOU COULD
RECEIVE FROM OUT OF STATE
TUITION. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION SENATOR- THE FUNDING
WHICH LIKE TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON THE NUANCES OF THE
FUNDING BUT THE PROPOSAL AS IT
IS- WOULD REPLACE. THE REVENUE
LOST FROM THOSE NON RESIDENTS.
I THINK WHAT I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT IS THAT THAT AMOUNT
WOULD THEN BE FIXED WELL AS ARE
NONRESIDENT SUPPLEMENTAL
TUITION. INCREASES WITH
INFLATION THAT AMOUNT WOULD
STAY THE SAME AND POTENTIALLY
DISAPPEAR IN A FUTURE RECESSION
WHICH IS WHAT WE FEAR- ALSO
IT'S FAR CHEAPER FOR YOU. TO
PROVIDE US WITH ENROLLMENT
GROWTH FUNDING FOR RESIDENT
STUDENTS THAT WOULD COST YOU
ABOUT TEN THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX DOLLARS PER
STUDENT. VERSUS THE PLAN IN
FRONT OF YOU THE REPLACE THOSE
NON RESIDENT STUDENTS WOULD
COST YOU. ABOUT 400-002-0080
FOUR DOLLARS PER STUDENT. WE
CAN WE CAN GROW CAPACITY FOR
NEXT FALL AND THE FOLLOWING
FALL AND LIKE CENTER LEARNED
SAID YOU CAN WORK WITH YOU ON A
CONSTRUCTION PLAN FOR
BUILDINGS. INCREASED OUR CAMPUS
CAPACITY EVEN FURTHER SO WE
WOULD REQUEST THAT YOU ALLOW
THE REGION'S PLAN TO STAY FOR
NOW. AND INSTEAD FOCUS ON
GROWING CALIFORNIA RESIDENT
UNDERGRADUATE ENROLLMENT
THROUGH. ANOTHER MEANS THANK
YOU. I THAT- NOW I HAD A
DIFFERENT LINE OF QUESTIONING-
I REALIZE WORTH LOOKING AT
ENROLLMENT- YOU KNOW WE'RE
OBVIOUSLY COMING OUT OF AN
UNUSUAL TIME AND I SUSPECT WILL
BE CARING FOR THIS CONVERSATION
AROUND NONRESIDENT STUDENTS-
FOR THE NEXT FEW YEARS BUT- AS
WE- EMERGE OUT OF THE COPA
PANDEMIC HOPEFULLY AND I ASSUME
THAT ALL THE U. SEASON CSU'S.
LOOKING TO. REOPEN PHYSICAL
INSTRUCTION I'M INTERESTED IN
IN HEARING ABOUT WHAT THE
SYSTEM Y. PLANS MIGHT BE ON A
COVERT PREVENTION- SAFETY AS
WELL AS- WHETHER YOU'RE
PLANNING TO OFFER ANY- ONLINE
OR VIRTUAL INSTRUCTION ASIDE
FROM THE 10% THE THAT THE
GOVERNOR WOULD LIKE TO SEE- FOR
THOSE STUDENTS WHO MAY NOT BE
COMFORTABLE COMING BACK IN AND
I. JUST LOOK AT THIS LA TIMES
STORY CAME OUT THIS WEEK HOUSE
ONLY 7% OF LOS ANGELES HIGH
SCHOOL SENIORS. I HAVE RETURNED
TO THE CLASSROOM AND I DON'T
KNOW WHAT WE SHOULD EXPECT OUT
OF. OUT OF A COLLEGE STUDENTS
BUT I'D BE INTERESTED TO HEAR
FROM YOU. KNOW WHAT YOUR
EXPECTATIONS ARE AND WHAT
YOU'RE PLANNING TO DO AND
WHETHER THOSE EFFORTS ARE
COVERED BY THE VARIOUS-
BUDGETARY ALLOCATIONS WHETHER
FEDERAL OR STATE THAT YOU'RE
RECEIVING. FAVOR TEN AND
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION SIR WE ARE
GOING TO BE MAKING A DECISION
ON RE OPENING OUR CAMPUSES
CLOSER TO JULY. WE'RE CURRENTLY
GATHERING INFORMATION ON HOW
MANY OF OUR STAFF FACULTY AND
STUDENTS ARE VACCINATED AT THE
MOMENT. WE WANT TO FOLLOW ALL
STATE AND FEDERAL GUIDELINES
FOR HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTION RE OPENING. WE HAVE
JUST INTRODUCED A DRAFT POLICY
THAT WE'RE GATHERING COMMENTS
ON. THE REQUIRE OF OUR STUDENTS
TO BE VACCINATED AGAINST KOBE
AND ONCE. UP FEDERAL FOOD AND
DRUG ADMINISTRATION HAS
PROVIDED FULL AUTHORIZATION FOR
THAT VACCINE. IT'S ON-
EMERGENCY AUTHORIZATION SO
WE'RE NOT REQUIRING THE VACCINE
FROM OUR STUDENTS AT THIS TIME-
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE 70% OF OUR-
STUDENTS FACULTY AND STAFF
OXIDATIVE BEFORE. WE CONSIDER
THE CAMPUSES- IT'S BY FAR
CORPORATE RE OPENING SO THERE
WILL BE UP FOR FALL. STILL
ONLINE COURSES AVAILABLE AND WE
HOPE TO MAKE SOME OF THOSE
ONLINE COURSES AVAILABLE
PERMANENTLY. UP FOR OUR
STUDENTS SO. THAT EVERYONE CAN
BE SAFE. THANK YOU AND FROM THE
CSU'S. SIR RYAN STORM VERY
SIMILAR TO WHAT- S. B. BRITTAN
WAS DESCRIBING I THINK OUR-
COMMENT POLICIES ALIGN VERY
CLOSELY WHERE OBVIOUSLY THERE'S
THE EMERGENCY AUTHORIZATION AND
THEY WILL BE REQUIRED FOR ALL
STAFF AND STUDENTS AND FACULTY-
IN THE FALL. THAT THEY WILL BE
VACCINATED- IN TERMS OF- COURSE
OFFERINGS WE HAVE A LOT OF A
LOT OF STUDENTS THAT ARE ARE
ARE DYING TO GET BACK ON CAMPUS
AND HAVE THAT COLLEGE
EXPERIENCE IN THAT IN IN PERSON
INTERACTION. IN SOARED CAMPUSES
ARE DOING THEIR BEST TO MAKE
SURE TAKEN OFFERS MADE THOSE
COURSES PLANNING TO OFFERS ME
THOSE COURSES POSSIBLE AS WELL
AS OFFER A LOT OF ONLINE
ALTERNATIVES AND OPTIONS THERE
TOO SO I THINK THE NEW NORMAL
GOING FORWARD IS GOING TO BE A
LOT MORE OFFERINGS OF HYBRID OR
FULLY ONLINE COURSE OFFERINGS
BECAUSE THERE HAS BEEN SOME
SUCCESS AND IT DOES WORK FOR. A
STUDENTS IN CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES- WHERE YOU KNOW
YOU MIGHT WANT TO PICK UP AN
ONLINE COURSE IN THE EVENING-
WHEREAS BEFORE THAT THE NORMAL
ATTENDING COLLEGE WAS TO BE
THERE IN PERSON DURING DURING
DAYLIGHT SO THOSE ARE OPTIONS
GOING FORWARD OF COURSE IS ALL
PREDICATED ON THE FACT OF HOW
THIS HOW THIS DISEASE NEWS AND
SHAKES AS WE GO FORWARD RIGHT-
RIGHT NOW THINGS ARE LOOKING
REALLY GOOD IN TERMS OF CASE
NUMBERS AND OUR ABILITY TO RE
OPEN AS MUCH AS WE CAN. BUT
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A BIG STAR OR
AN ACTOR ASTERIX BY IT WHERE
WHERE AS WE JUST HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO ATTEND IT IF THINGS
CHANGE DRAMATICALLY BUT- I
THINK WE'RE IN PRETTY GOOD
SHAPE IN TERMS OF THE FUNDING
THAT'S THAT'S NECESSARY TO
SUPPORT THAT REPOPULATION AND
YOU NEED AND EVEN ONLINE
OFFERINGS. THERE IS A
CONSIDERABLE ABOUT AMOUNT OF
FUNDING FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT SUPPLIED TO
EACH OF OUR CAMPUSES DIRECTLY
TO OFFER- BOTH OF THOSE- BOTH
OF THOSE PIECES SO I WOULD SAY
FROM ACT DEALING WITH COVANTA
AND THE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
SAID WE HAVE AMPLE MONEY THERE
TO DEAL WITH THOSE PIECES
DIRECTLY. I APPRECIATE. THAT
ANSWER AND I ALSO WOULD BE
REMISS IF I DIDN'T CONGRATULATE
THE UC RIGHT- ON. THE ASK ANY
PERFORMING- A VERY YOU SEASON
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA. BERKELEY
IN THIS WEEK'S- I FORGET HIS U.
S. NEWS OR PRINCETON REVIEW BUT
THAT. WAS A CONGRATULATIONS ON
THAT PERFORMANCE. THANK YOU A.
N. I ALSO WANNA I NOTICE YOU
PAUSED AFTER YOU SEE AND THEN
ADDED BERKELEY AND WE'VE HAD
TWO CONFIRMATIONS IN FRONT OF
THE RULES COMMITTEE. INCLUDING
THE COMMANDER OF THE HIGHWAY
PATROL LAST WEEK WHERE SHE JUST
LISTED UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
ON A RESUME NOTHING ELSE AND
THEN IF COULD SHE JUST ASSUMED
WE ALL KNEW THAT IT MEANT
BERKELEY AND SO I CALLED HER
OUT UNDER CHAUVINISM BY TEN
FROM UC IRVINE SO YEAH SONORA
FROM THAT AND I'M A SLOW GETS
EXTREMELY PROBLEMATIC. SENATE
ROAD SHOW ABOVE DID YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS NO QUESTIONS WERE
GOOD SO THAT COMPLETES THIS
ITEM AND IT WAS AN ANIMATED
DISCUSSION WILL TAKE IT ALL
INTO ACCOUNT I WANT TO THANK.
OUR PANELISTS FOR PARTICIPATING
AND WE WILL MOVE TO THE THIRD
AND LAST ITEM WHICH IS DEBT
FREE COLLEGE INTO HERE
BASICALLY THE SENATE'S A
PROPOSAL ON THE SUBJECT AND THE
FOUR PANELISTS ARE. WITH A CAME
FROM THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE LARA SAYS BEAUCOUP BIRDS
FROM THE INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE
ACCESS AND SUCCESS JERRY
BREMNER FROM THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION AND
GABRIELA CHAVEZ FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE'LL DO
IT IN. THE IN THAT ORDER AND
BEGIN WITH. THE L. A. L.
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU TO MY TEN MEMBERS. BE
THINKING WITH THE LEAD TO PANEL
OFFICE. AS HE NOTED WITH AN
ASPECT COMMITTEE STAFF TODAY TO
PRESENT THE SENATE DEMOCRATS
PLAN FOR DEBT FREE COLLEGE.
DISCIPLINE CONSISTS OF VARIOUS
OPTIONS WHICH YOU'LL SEE
OUTLINED IN YOUR CHEN DEAD
BEGINNING AT THE BOTTOM OF PAGE
FOURTEEN. THE FIRST SET OF
OPTIONS FOR LATEST EXPANDING
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE ALREADY.
WELL HOW CANCER NEED BASED
PROGRAM THERE ARE CURRENTLY A
NUMBER OF ELIGIBILITY RULES IN
ADDITION TO FINANCIAL.
SPECIFICALLY STUDENTS MUST HAVE
A GRADE POINT AVERAGE OF AT
LEAST TWO POINT OH OR HIGHER
FOR CERTAIN TALKING AWAY TYPES.
AS WE DISCUSSED IN A SEPARATE
HEARING THERE ARE ALSO SOME
REQUIREMENTS RELATING TO AGING
TIME OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL
CURRENTLY ONLY RECENT HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATES AND TRANSFER
STUDENTS UNDER AGE TWENTY EIGHT
OUR ENTITLED TO ACCOUNT GRANT
SHOULD THE INTELLIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS. OLDER STUDENTS
ARE CONSIDERED FOR ONE OF A
LIMITED NUMBER OF COMPETITIVE
AWARDS. NOTES THAT THE
SUBCOMMITTEE COULD CONSIDER.
REMOVING HIS ELIGIBILITY
VARIOUS WRITING TO AGING TIME
OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL FOR THE
ENTITLEMENT PROGRAM. AS WELL AS
REMOVING THE GPA REQUIREMENTS
FOR CONTENTS WERE PROMPTLY.
DOING SO IS ESTIMATED TO ADD A
FEW HUNDRED THOUSAND RECIPIENTS
TO THE CAL GRANT PROGRAMS. THE
SECOND BUCKET OF OPTIONS BEFORE
YOU IS RELATED TO TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE. CURRENTLY THE
MAJORITY OF CALVIN FUNDING GOES
TOWARD PROVIDING STUDENTS WITH
TUITION COVERAGE. OPTIONS HERE
BEFORE YOU ARE RELATED TO
ASSISTING STUDENTS WITH THEIR
LIVING COSTS SUCH AS FOOD AND
HOUSING. THE ACCESSIBLE WORK
THIS IS A NONTRADITIONAL ARE
CURRENTLY WORTH ABOUT SIXTEEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS A YEAR. FOR THE
LOWER INCOME TALKING RECIPIENTS
RECEIVING THAT THE AWARD. THE
SUBCOMMITTEE TO CONSIDER
INCREASING THE AWARD AMOUNT.
THERE IS ALSO AN OPTION RELATED
TO THE STUDENT SUCCESS
COMPLETION GRANT THIS IS A
SUPPLEMENTAL WORK AVAILABLE TO
CALLAHAN RECIPIENTS THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN FAIRFIELD
FULL TIME. THE OPTION IS TO
EITHER INCREASE THE AWARD
AMOUNT ABOVE THE CURRENT LEVEL
OF UP TO FORTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
A YEAR. OR TO INCREASE DEBT
PROGRAM EXTEND THE PROGRAM TO
ALSO INCLUDE PART TIME STUDENTS
WILL JUST COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
RELATED TO THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP. BUT YOU KNOW
CURRENTLY THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM PROVIDES
PARTIAL TUITION COVERAGE TO
CERTAIN STUDENTS AT CSU AND UC.
UNDER THE VERSION OF THE
PROGRAM OUTLINED IN YOUR AGENDA
THE TOPIC PAGE SIXTEEN. MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP WOULD BE
FUNDAMENTALLY RESTRUCTURED TO
PROVIDE YOU SEEN CSU STUDENTS
WITH ADDITIONAL ASSISTANCE WITH
THE TOTAL COST OF ATTENDANCE.
THE FORMULA THE TOUGHEST
SIXTEEN VERSION OF IT OUTLINES
HOW THE WORD AMOUNTS TO BE
DETERMINED UNDER THIS PROPOSED
STRUCTURE. FOR EACH STUDENT
WOULD START WITH THE TOTAL COST
OF ATTENDANCE AND THEN SUBTRACT
OUT THERE AVAILABLE RESOURCES
MEANING THERE OTHER FORMS OF
FINANCIAL AID. EXPECTED FAMILY
CONTRIBUTION PROPS MODIFIED
FROM THE FEDERAL AMOUNTS. BUT
ALSO STUDENT CONTRIBUTION FROM
PART TIME WORKER EARNINGS. THE
DIFFERENCE WOULD BE THAT AXONAL
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP WORK. THIS
RESTRUCTURING WOULD REPRESENT A
SIGNIFICANT EXPANSION OF THE
PROGRAM BOTH IN TERMS OF THE
NUMBER OF RECIPIENTS IT COULD
SERVE AS WELL AS THE- BOARD
ANNOUNCED I IN TERMS OF OVERALL
STATED THAT STUDENTS AT UC AND
CSU LITERACY. THERE IS ONE
ADDITIONAL OPTION LISTING YOUR
GENDER RELATING TO STUDENT LOAN
THAT. THE CURRENT STATE LAW TAX
FILERS MAY DEDUCT UP TO TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED IN STUDENT LOAN
INTEREST PAYMENTS FROM THEIR
TAXABLE INCOME. HERE IS TO
EITHER INCREASE THE MAXIMUM
DEDUCTION. OR INCREASE THE
INCOME CEILINGS OUT WHICH TAX
FILERS CAN CLAIM THAT BOB. THE
COST OF THE SENATE STAFFER
COLLEGE PACKAGE IS GOING TO
DEPEND ON WHICH OF THESE
VARIOUS OPTIONS IF IT CHOOSES
TO PURSUE. BUT WORKING WITH
YOUR STAFF WE THINK THAT IF THE
SENATE WERE TO PURSUE ALL OF
THESE OPTIONS AND ONCE AND THE
PRELIMINARY COST ESTIMATE FOR
THE PLAN WOULD BE IN THE RANGE
OF FIVE BILLION DOLLARS. BE
HAPPY TAKING QUESTIONS WILL
CORPORATE TIME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS WILL
MOVE TO THE- INSTITUTE FOR
COLLEGE ACCESS AND SUCCESS.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU FOR
INVITING ME TODAY THE INSTITUTE
FOR COLLEGE ACCESS AND SUCCESS
OR HE GETS AS A RESEARCH DESIGN
AN ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION FOR
STUDENT CENTER POLICIES. THAT
PROMOTE AFFORDABILITY
ACCOUNTABILITY AND EQUITY IN
HIGHER EDUCATION. MY NAME IS
LAURA SZABO CUBITS AND I
SERVICE ORGANIZATIONS CALL
CALIFORNIA FOR ABILITY PROGRAM
DIRECTOR AND WE ARE COALITION
OF CALIFORNIANS FOR COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY. FOR MORE THAN A
DECADE TO GUESS ANALYSES HAVE
SHOWN THAT STUDENTS ACROSS THE
STATE FACED SIGNIFICANT
AFFORDABILITY CHALLENGES IN
GREAT PART DUE TO MINIMAL
SUPPORT FOR NON TUITION
EXPENSES. THAT MAKE UP THE
MAJORITY OF MOST STUDENTS TOTAL
COLLEGE COSTS. THESE
AFFORDABILITY CHALLENGES FALL
MOST HEAVILY ON THE LOWEST
INCOME CALIFORNIANS CRAFTER
AVAILABLE GRANT AID MUST FIGHT
ABOUT HALF OF THEIR INCOME
TOWARDS COVERING COLLEGE COSTS.
THIS HAS SIGNIFICANT RACIAL
EQUITY IMPLICATIONS WHAT THE
MAJORITY OF THE STATE'S BLACK
LATIN ACTS AND NATIVE AMERICAN
STUDENTS FAMILIES EARNING LESS
THAN THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY. WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR
THE SENATE ON GOING COMMITMENT
TO STRENGTHENING STATE NEED
BASED FINANCIAL AID SO THAT LOW
INCOME STUDENT SUCCESS IS NOT
CURTAILED BY UNAFFORDABLE
COSTS. BURDENSOME DEBT WHICH
COULD NINETEEN HAS ONLY
EXACERBATED AND APPLAUD THE
BILL BACK ALL THE PLAN FOR
ADDRESSING THESE CONCERNS. WELL
THERE ARE MANY IMPORTANT STEPS
TO REFORM STATE FINANCIAL AID
THE TOP PRIORITIESSHOULD BE
EXTENDING AN ENTITLEMENT CAL
GRANT TO AT LEAST ALL STUDENTS.
WITH PELL GRANT ELIGIBLE
FINANCIAL CIRCUMSTANCES AND
INSURING THE VALUE OF THE
ACCESS TO WORK THAT HELPS COVER
NON TUITION COSTS IS AT MINIMUM
MAINTAINED AND TIED TO AN
ENORMOUS FACTOR. THE SENATE
STILL BAFFLES EACH PLAN ALIGNS
TO THESE PRIORITIES IN TWO
IMPORTANT WAYS. FIRST IT
EXPANDS THE CALTRAIN
ENTITLEMENT AYE REMOVING THE
AGE CAP AND ONE YEAR OUT OF
HIGH SCHOOL SORT OF CAPS
NONTRADITIONAL STUDENTS FROM
RECEIVING AN AWARD. ALSO THE
PROPOSAL TO REPLACE GPA WITH A
GOOD STANDING REQUIREMENTS WILL
HELP ENSURE THE PROGRAM IS
CONSISTENT WITH OTHER MAJOR
FINANCIAL. AID PROGRAMS LIKE
THE FEDERAL PELL GRANT. SECOND
BMC TWO POINT NOW WE'RE CREATE
STATE OF. GUARANTEE WE'RE NO
STUDENT HAS TO WORK MORE THAN
FIFTEEN HOURS A WEEK WITH
GRANTED COVERING REMAINING NEED
FOR TOTAL COLLEGE COSTS. IS ALL
CAN BE STRENGTHENED IN A COUPLE
OF IMPORTANT WAY. GIVEN THE
DEGREE TO WHICH TEAM UNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS LACK ACCESS TO
SEEK FINANCIAL AID RECEIVING
JUST 7% OF CAL GRANT DOLLARS
DESPITE SERVING TWO THIRDS OF
THE STATE'S COLLEGE STUDENTS
MANY OF WHOM ARE LOW INCOME WE
URGE YOU TO INCLUDE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS UNDER ANY
AFFORDABILITY PLEDGE.
ADDITIONALLY TO THE DEGREE THAT
STATE RESOURCES ARE LIMITED WE
URGE LAWMAKERS TO PRIORITIZE
MEETING THE FINANCIAL AID NEEDS
OF THE LOWEST IN CONCERT. THIS
IS PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT
CONSIDERING THE RACIAL EQUITY
IMPLICATIONS FOR THIS
POPULATION. WE ALSO APPRECIATE
THE SENATE'S RECOGNITION OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF PROVIDING RELIEF
TO STUDENTS BURDENED BY DEBT.
AS DISCUSSED IN TODAY'S AGENDA
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT LOW INCOME
AND UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS
OF COLOR CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES ARE MUCH MORE
LIKELY TO GRADUATE WITH THAT.
BUT NO BETTER RESOURCE HERE.
ENSURING THE MOST VULNERABLE
STUDENTS ARE PRIORITIZE FOR
STUDENT DEBT RELIEF WILL BE
CRITICAL IN CLOSING THE STATE'S
EQUITY GAPS. WE ARE EXCITED
ABOUT THE BOLD STEPS OUTLINED
BY THE SENATE PROPOSAL AND ARE
GRATEFUL FOR YOUR ON GOING
COMMITMENT TO MAKING COLLEGE IN
CALIFORNIA AFFORDABLE. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
TOGETHER WITH BOTH HOUSING. FOR
THE STATE BUDGET INCLUDES
FUNDING BUT ADEQUATELY SUPPORT
THESE GOALS AND THOSE OF THE
CAL GRANT EQUITY FRAMEWORK.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME FOR ALL
YOU DO TO SUPPORT CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND THEN WILL MOVE TO A JAKE
BRUNNER FROM THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR LAYERED AND
SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN YOU
AGAIN- THIS MORNING- AND FOR
THE FOCUS OF THIS SUBCOMMITTEE
AND HER COLLEAGUES- ON HOW
CALIFORNIA CAN PROVIDE STUDENTS
WITH AFFORDABLE OPPORTUNITIES.
TO BENEFIT FROM OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEMS. AS YOU HEARD
WHEN I JOIN THE SUBCOMMITTEE IN
FEBRUARY WE AT THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION SHARE
YOUR FOCUS AND REMOVING THE
BARRIERS THAT PREVENT STUDENTS
FROM ACCESSING A CAL GRANT. AS
WELL AS EXPANDING THE SUPPORT
AVAILABLE FOR NON TUITION
EXPENSES. SINCE THAT FEBRUARY
HEARING WE AT THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION RELEASED
AN UPDATED VERSION OF OUR CAL
GRANT EQUITY FRAMEWORK PROPOSAL
THAT SHARES MANY KEY FEATURES
AND FOCUSES WITH WHAT THE
SENATE HAS OUTLINED IN THE BILL
BACK BOLDLY PLAN. AS THE SENATE
HAS PROPOSED THE CAL GRANT
EQUITY FRAMEWORK WOULD ALSO
REMOVE THE OUTDATED ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS BASED ON AGE WHEN
HIS STUDENTS GRADUATED HIGH
SCHOOL. AND GPA ALL OF WHICH
KEEP OUT HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF STUDENTS. EACH YEAR FROM
ACCESSING A CALTRANS. AS
SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS MAY ALSO
RECALL THE CAL GRANT EQUITY
FRAMEWORK ACHIEVES THIS BY
ESTABLISHING A TOLERANT TO AND
CAL GRANT FOR IN PLACE OF THE
CURRENT SIX VARIOUS CAL GRANT
PROGRAMS. THIS SIMPLIFICATION
WILL MAKE STATE FINANCIAL AID
MORE UNDERSTANDABLE FOR
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES AS WELL
AS EASIER TO COMMUNICATE FOR
COUNSELORS AND EDUCATORS. IN
THE UPDATED VERSION OF THE
PROPOSAL RELEASED IN APRIL
WE'VE ALIGNED THE FINANCIAL
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS FOR
THE CAL GRANT YOU AND THE CAL
GRANT WILL WORK WITH THE NEW
FEDERAL STUDENT AID SYSTEM THAT
WILL BEGIN IN THE FINANCIAL AID
APPLICATION CYCLE. OPENING IN
OCTOBER OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
THIS IS THE STUDENT AID INDEX
IT IS REPLACING WHAT- WE
CURRENTLY USE AS THE EXPECTED
FAMILY CONTRIBUTION AND I WILL
ALSO NOTE THAT IN THIS UPDATED
VERSION OF THE PROPOSAL. WE
WOULD NOT ONLY MAKE AN
ADDITIONAL TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS ELIGIBLE FOR
FINANCIAL AID THE WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT AS WE
EXPAND THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS
THAT WE CONSERVE. WE MAINTAIN
THE CURRENT ACCESS AWARD
AMOUNTS TO BE- POINT THAT WAS
JUST RAISED BY MYSELF- CUBITS.
SHOULD CALIFORNIA ADOPT THE
CALTRAIN EQUITY FRAMEWORK WE
CAN NOT ONLY REMOVE BARRIERS TO
STUDENT ELIGIBILITY FOR STATE
AID. BUT ALSO A LINE CALIFORNIA
SYSTEM WITH THE NEW FEDERAL ONE
BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO
AS I JUST MENTIONED. THIS WOULD
AVOID THE CURRENT CHALLENGES
THAT STUDENTS AND FAMILIES FACE
WHEN ASSESSING THE FINANCIAL
AID THAT. THEY COULD ACCESS AND
HAVING CURRENTLY TWO SEPARATE
SETS OF STANDARDS TO UNDERSTAND
ONE FOR FEDERAL AID ONE FOR
STATE IT. IN ESTABLISHING CAL
GRANT TO FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS AND CAL GRANT FOR OUR
STUDENTS AND OUR FOUR YEAR
INSTITUTIONS WE CAN ALSO TAILOR
EACH PROGRAMS REFLECT THE
UNIQUE NEEDS OF THOSE STUDENTS.
ONE IMPORTANT ASPECT OF THIS IS
THAT THE PROPOSED CAL GRANT YOU
WOULD HAVE A LATER APPLICATION
DEADLINE OF SEPTEMBER SECOND.
WHICH REFLECTS THE OPEN ACCESS
NATURE OF OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND WOULD ALLOW THOSE
LATER DECIDING STUDENTS TO
STILL ACCESS FINANCIAL AID.
THIS WOULD ALSO ALLOW US TO
MAINTAIN THE MARCH SECOND.
FILING DEADLINE FOR CAL GRANT
FOR AWARD WHICH IS IMPORTANT TO
ALLOW FOR FINANCIAL AID
PACKAGING TO OCCUR AT THE
CAMPUS LEVEL AS WELL AS FOR
THOSE FINANCIAL AID PACKAGES TO
BE EXTENDED TO STUDENTS. AS
THEY CONSIDER AT WHICH
INSTITUTION THEY'RE GOING TO
ENROLL. THE CALTRAIN EQUITY
FRAMEWORK IS THE PRODUCT OF
YEARS OF DIALOGUE OF THE
COMMISSION WITH STUDENTS WITH
HIGHER EDUCATION SEGMENTS AND
OTHER KEY STAKEHOLDERS. I'M ALL
OF WHICH CULMINATED IN THE
CALTRAIN PERFORM WORKERS AT A
BEEN REQUESTED BY SENATOR LEYVA
pMCCARTY. AS THE SENATE
CONSIDERS HOW TO MAKE FINANCIAL
AID AND HIGHER EDUCATION MORE
ACCESSIBLE WE HOPE THAT THIS
FRAMEWORK CAN SERVE AS A
STARTING PLACE FOR THAT
DISCUSSION. AND AT THE
COMMISSION CAN BE A RESOURCE TO
YOUR DEVELOPMENT OF THIS
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN. AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND
WILL MOVE TO GABRIELA CHAVEZ
FROM THE DEPARTMENT FUNDS. THE
MORNING CHEN MEMBERS GOVERNOR
LIKE CHáVEZ WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ON THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSALS-
UNDERSTOOD IN THE COMMISSION.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
THINK IN A MOMENT I'M GONNA SEE
IF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE QUESTIONS
BUT I THOUGHT. RATHER THAN
QUESTIONS I WOULD MAKE A BRIEF
STATEMENT HERE- WHICH IS THAT
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE WAITING FOR THE
MAY REVISE ITS TWO DAYS AWAY.
AND AS I MENTIONED DURING THE
OPENING COMMENTS THE SENATE HAS
HAD. ITS OF PLAN OF FOR DEBT
FREE COLLEGES AS PART OF ITS A
BILL BACKED BOLDLY A BUDGET
EFFORT. AND THAT THE GOVERNOR
INTERESTINGLY ONE BY ONE
WHETHER IT'S- WITH THE PARTS OF
THE STIMULUS TO DROUGHT PACKAGE
THE WILDLIFE FOR WILDFIRE
PACKAGE WIDDOP THAT ALREADY. OR
WHAT HE'S DOING WITH US SOME OF
THE K. THROUGH TWELVE AND
PRESCHOOL THINGS. HE'S TRACKING
THE BOXES THAT THE SENATE HAD
LAID OUT SO WE CAN ONLY HOPE
THAT HE CHECKS THIS BOX ON ON
FRIDAY WITH WHAT HE PROPOSES.
BUT I THINK THE SIGNIFICANT
THING HERE IS. IS THAT THE
EXISTING STUDENT AID SYSTEM
SEEMS TO HAVE LIMITS IN PLACE.
THAT JUST HELP GET TO AN
EXISTING AN ADEQUATE AMOUNT OF
MONEY TO PROVIDE THE GRANTS AND
WOULD PROVIDE THE NUMBER OF
GRANTS. AND THAT WHAT REALLY
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED IS. IS
BROADER GRANTS IN TERMS OF CAR
X. BEYOND FEES BUT SECOND WORRY-
TO INCLUDE PEOPLE THAT HAVE
BEEN EXCLUDED UNDER THESE WHAT
I THINK ARE ARE ARTIFICIAL
REALLY. OF LIMITS THAT ARE
UNFORTUNATE SO THAT REENTRY
STUDENTS CAN QUALIFY. ARE THAT
THERE ARE OTHER THINGS THAT
SORT OF OUR PART OF THE FACTORS
THAT LIMIT PEOPLE AND I THINK
THAT'S WHAT THE PLAN DOES IT
WOULD ADD HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF STUDENTS. IN A WAY THAT IT
TRULY WOULD GET TO A DEBT FREE
COLLEGE OR MANY PEOPLE AND IT
WOULD PRIORITIZE THOSE IS ONE
OF THE COMMON OR SAID. ABOUT
FOUR OR AT THE LOWEST INCOMES
AS WELL AS BEEFING UP THE
MIDDLE CLASS OF PROGRAMS WHILE.
AND SO I THINK THIS IS AN
INCREDIBLE EFFORT AND WE HAVE.
THIS OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE IF YOU
JUST LOOK AT THE BUDGET FOR THE
LAST TWO DECADES WE'RE JUST
DOING TRIAGE ON EVERYTHING.
THIS GIVES US THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BUDGET FOR IMPACT IT ANOTHER
NUMBER OF PLACES AND THIS IS
ONE. THAT WOULD JUST MAKE A
FUNDAMENTAL DIFFERENCE IN THE
AFFORDABILITY AND THE ABILITY
OF CALIFORNIANS TO ACCESS
HIGHER EDUCATION AND IRONICALLY
WE SPOKE ABOUT. FEES AND
LIMITATIONS AND CAPACITY IN THE
PRIOR ITEMS I MEAN WE MAY HAVE
TO REVISIT THOSE IF WE ACTUALLY
MAKE IT EASIER FOR PEOPLE TO
AFFORD TO GO TO COLLEGE BUT
THAT'S WHAT. THIS DOES AND SO I
THINK RATHER THAN ASK QUESTIONS
I'M JUST GOING TO OFFER THESE
COMMENTS AND THE COMMENTS THAT
I HEARD WATCHED SOME OF. THE
WITNESSES SAID ON THE PANEL AND
OBVIOUSLY WE WOULD LOOK AT ANY
FINE TUNING IF WE HAVE TO DO IT
AS WE MOVE ALONG SO I JUST WANT
TO MAKE THOSE COMMENTS. ON THE
ENTIRE ITEM AND ASK MY
COLLEAGUES IF THERE ARE ANY
QUESTIONS. NON FROM SENATOR MAN
SENATOR TROUBLE. YES YOUR
MICROPHONE YEAH. I'M JUST A
QUICK QUESTION AND I THINK IT
WAS- IT WAS ADDRESSED EARLIER
TODAY BY FOR CLARIFICATION
PURSES OUR PURPOSE IS MOVING
FORWARD HAS THERE BEEN A COST
ANALYSIS OF WHAT THE TOTAL COST
TO IMPLEMENT BOTH THE SENATE
PLAN FOR REDUCING AT A STATE
RESIDENT INVOLVEMENT AND THE
DEBT FREE COLLEGE PACKAGE WILL
BE. MARMOSET DIRECTED TO A
PARTICULAR ONE OF THE WITNESSES
I'M GOING TO HAVE. THE FINANCE.
WHOA OF THE L. A. O. HAS YOUR
HAND UP LET'S SEE IF SHE HAS
HER HAND UP TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION OR IT WAS A RANDOM
HAND UP SO- OF RECOGNIZED THE
OHIO AND HOPE SHE CAN ADDRESS
THE QUESTION. LISTICLE OF THE
ALLEY AND- I WITH REGARDS
TODAY'S STAFFING PACKAGE. ON
AS- AS- AND THAT ARE PULLING A
COST ESTIMATE FOR THIS PLAN IS
APPROXIMATELY FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS THAT DOESN'T SEEM THAT
ALL OF THE OPTIONS THAT WE
DISCUSSED EARLIER. WOULD BE
PURSUED. IF THE SENATE WHERE TO
PURSUE CERTAIN ELEMENTS OF THE
PLAN FOR EXAMPLE JUST REMOVING
THE BARRIERS RELATING TO EACH
IN TIME OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL OR
JUST EXPANDING THE COW CAN
ACCESS AWARD. AND THE COST
WOULD BE JUST A FRACTION OF
THAT AMOUNT AND WILL BE HAPPY
TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH
COMMITTEE STAFF. TO REFINE THIS
ESTIMATE. N. OR JUST OFF THE
COMMON TO. THE THAT THERE'S A
STRUGGLE HERE BETWEEN THE
BRANCHES AND WHAT IS FUNDED AND
I KNOW THAT- OF THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION. I THINK IT WAS THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION BUT
WONDERFUL MENTIONED COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WHICH WOULD BE A HEFTY
COST IF THAT CAME AND THEN
THAT'S NOT NECESSARILY AND SOME
OF THE VERSIONS AND SO. IT WILL
BE SOME OF THOSE DECISIONS THAT
WOULD BE MADE. THAT WOULD
ACTUALLY DECIDE WHAT THE COSTS
WOULD BE. OKAY IDEA FOR THE
QUESTIONS JUST ONE MORE AND I'M
NOT SURE AB WHO DO BEST TO
ANSWER THAT- SO WITH THE STATE
FUNDING AND TRYING TO GET THE
DEBT FREE COLLEGE. IS THERE ANY
THING IN PLACE THAT WOULD
INCENTIVIZE KEEPING THE COST OF
ATTENDING COLLEGE- AT LOWER-
AT. A LOWER PORTION. IT JUST
SEEMS IF WE- IF WE ARE
COMMITTING OURSELVES AS A STATE
TO FULLY FIND STATE COLLEGE
THEN THE COST OF TUITION AND
EVERYTHING ELSE THAT GOES INTO
ATTENDING COLLEGE IS THERE ANY
INCENTIVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY REMAIN AT A CONSTANT OR
OR- AFFORDABLE FOR THE LONG
TERM. I THINK I'M JUST GOING TO
TAKE A STAB AT THAT IT IT'S
BECAUSE- MMHM. THE THERE WERE
THERE ARE REALLY TWO THAT MIGHT
BE WITHIN OUR CONTROL F. AND
THAT WOULD BE THE FEES AND THE
OVERALL COST OF OUR OF THE
INSTITUTION THAT RESULTS IN THE
LEVEL FEES AND THEN BOXES TO
THE EXTENT THAT WE DO ANYTHING
WITH REGARD TO BOOKS BY HOUSING
AND FOOD AND OTHER THINGS ARE
NOT THINGS THAT CAN. SEE A
RADICALLY THE A AND I KNOW THAT
BECAUSE OF THE BLOWING UP
HOUSING MARKET IN MY HOME
REGION THE LATEST LONG RANGE
DEVELOPMENT CLIENT PLAN FOR THE
UNIVERSITY WOULD PUT A 100% OF
NEW CAMPUS GROWTH ON CAMPUS
WITH CAMPUS HOUSING AND THEY
WERE CONSTRUCTED BUT WAS AS
MENTIONED IN THE PREVIOUS ITEM.
THE UC SYSTEM FOR HOUSING IS-
CHALLENGING MORE WHO ARE
LOOKING FOR THE RIGHT WORK
BECAUSE THEY ARE LOW THE NEW
HOUSING PROJECT IN AND THEN
PEOPLE AREN'T BUILT FOR THE
COST OF THAT PROJECT THAT JUST
GOES IN AND SPREAD AMONG ALL
PEOPLE. ARE AMONG ALL
FACILITIES ARE IN A COMMON
PAYMENT ARE LEVEL AND SO IT'S
TO THE EXTENT THAT THE WORKING
WITH THE UNIVERSITY FOR THE CSU
COMMUNITY COLLEGES COULD BE
MORE EFFICIENT IN WHAT THEY DO
IT IN THEIR COST NOT BEING
HIGHER FOR WE COULD DO
SOMETHING THAT LIMITS. SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT ARE IN THE COST
OF BOOKS WHICH IS BEEN
DISCUSSED AND ACTED UPON A
DIFFERENT PLACE BUT OTHER
THINGS ARE WITH I THINK A
LITTLE BIT OUT OF CONTROL. I
THINK DOES THAT ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION GREAT I THINK A CENTER
MEN HAD A COMMON. YEAH I JUST
WANTED TO HAVE LIKE SENATOR
LEAHY CARE LAYERED I HAVE MAKE
A BRIEF COMMENT HERE WE JUST
SAW RECENTLY THAT. CALIFORNIA
EXPERIENCED A DECLINE IN
POPULATION THE PAST YEAR. AND
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT THE CAUSES
OF CALIFORNIANS- THE CLIENT
POPULATION. YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT
THE COST OF LIVING HERE AND
PART OF THAT'S ACOSTA HOUSING A
PART OF THAT IS AFFECTED SO
MANY STUDENTS GRADUATE. WITH
UNSUSTAINABLE LEVELS OF DEBT
AND SO I REALLY APPLAUD THIS
GENERAL THRUST TOWARDS- TRYING
TO INCREASE STUDENT AID. HI
MAKE COLLEGE DEBT FREE AND IN
PARTICULAR I THINK IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TO DESIGN THESE
PROGRAMS WHILE THESE EFFORTS
WELL AND- THE OBVIOUS ADVICE
BECAUSE I'M IN THE STATE SENATE
BUT I THINK THE SENATE'S BILL
BACKED BOLDLY PLANT. ALSO HAS
THE BENEFIT OF BEING RELATIVELY
SIMPLE I KNOW THAT TOO MANY
STUDENTS IN HIGH SCHOOL. I JUST
ARE OVERWHELMED WITH ALL THE
DIFFERENT- AIDING GRANT TACTIC
IS AVAILABLE TO THEM AND I
THINK. THE BENEFIT WHEN WE TRY
TO MAKE THESE SIMPLER EASIER TO
UNDERSTAND PROGRAMS THAT
AUTOMATICALLY KICK IN AND SO- I
JUST WANT TO FLOOD THE
ARCHITECTS OF THIS PLAN FOR
THAT- AND APPLAUD YOU ALL FOR
YOUR EFFORTS TO TRY TO MAKE
COLLEGE. MORE AFFORDABLE FOR
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE. AND LET ME
SUBSCRIBE TO THAT AND THEN I DO
CAN'T HELP BUT ADD. IN THAT IS.
IT WHEN I WAS CHOOSING TO RUN
FOR THE SENATE. I HAD A VERY.
SELF REVEALING MOMENT WHEN I
REALIZED THAT I HAD JUST COME
OF AGE IN A UNIQUE TIME IN
CALIFORNIA VERY LUCKY- YOU KNOW
THE BABY BOOM AN- SO I MANAGED
TO EVEN THOUGH MY MOTHER WENT
BACK TO COLLEGE AT THE SAME
TIME AS ME. AND MY FATHER WAS
WORKING AS A TEACHER I MANAGED
TO GET OUT OF COLLEGE WITHOUT
DEBT AND I WAS ABLE TO BUY A
HOUSE AND IT'S LIKE WHAT COULD
I AS A SENATOR DO. TO AFFECT
THOSE EXISTENTIAL QUESTIONS OF
AFFORDABILITY FOR THE NEXT
GENERATION WHO DO NOT FEEL A
STAKE IN OUR SYSTEM WHETHER
IT'S HOUSING- OR WHETHER IT'S-
IT- FEES. COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY
OR WHETHER IT'S JUST THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE NOT LEFT CLIMATE
IT'S GOING TO BE GOOD FOR THE
NEXT THIRTY OR FORTY YEARS WHAT
CAN WE DO. THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
THINGS THAT COULD FUNDAMENTALLY
CHANGE. WHETHER PEOPLE MIGHT BE
ABLE TO START MOVING TOWARD
HOUSING BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
JUST MORTGAGING THEIR LIFE AWAY
TO GO TO COLLEGE AND I THINK.
IT'S RARE THAT WE CAN MAKE A
FUNDAMENTAL DIFFERENCE LIKE
THAT AND THAT'S WHAT THIS IS
AND THAT IS WHAT IS IMPORTANT.
SO I'M GOING TO THANK OR PANEL
AND I KNOW THERE WILL BE
CONTINUED DISCUSSIONS. AND THE
ONE THING THAT WE HAVE LEFT IS
TO HEAR FROM MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC ON ANYTHING. THAT WE
MIGHT HAVE DISCUSSED ON THE
FREE ITEMS TODAY AND I AM GOING
TO GO FIRST. BUT TO THE ROOM
THAT MORAN AND GENERALLY WE
LIMIT TO A MINUTE BUT WE'LL SEE
IF I HAVE TO REVISIT THAT AFTER
FIVE HUNDRED PEOPLE ON THE LINE
OR SOMETHING SO- WE'RE GOING
THIS COMMITTEE ROOM WITH TWO
PEOPLE THAT I CAN SEE WELCOME
TO THE COMMITTEE. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS I'M
CRISTINA CARO REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA LIBRARY ASSOCIATION
COMMENTING ON THE PUBLIC
LIBRARY PACKAGE THAT'S BEFORE
YOU TODAY. CLA IS A VERY
GRATEFUL TO THE SENATE
DEMOCRATS FOR THIS GAME
CHANGING PROPOSAL THAT IS
UNPRECEDENTED IN ITS SIZE AND
SCOPE. AND WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT I'M GOING TO SPEAK TO
THE INFRASTRUCTURE PIECE TODAY.
THE COMMITTEE BACKGROUNDER DOES
A GREAT JOB OF HIGHLIGHTING THE
HUGE INFRASTRUCTURE NEED FOR
PUBLIC LIBRARIES. FILLETS NEEDS
ASSESSMENT IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
REVEALED THAT WE HAVE NO. END
OF BASIC FUNCTIONALITY
CHALLENGES THAT LIBRARY SUCH AS
ADA COMPLIANCE ISSUES. DRY ROT
LEAKING ROOFS AND CROWDED
CHILDREN'S ROOMS. LAST WEEK THE
PASADENA PUBLIC LIBRARY. CLOSED
INDEFINITELY BECAUSE OF SERIOUS
SEISMIC SAFETY CONCERNS. AND
USING ONE TIME BUDGET PLANS IS
THE PERFECT WAY TO ADDRESS OUR
AGING LIBRARIES. CONNECTING
MORE PUBLIC LIBRARIES TO THE
BROADBAND BACKBONE OPERATED BY
SCENIC IS ALSO A HIGH PRIORITY
FOR CLA. AND THE PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN CLA SCENIC AND THE
STATE LIBRARY HAS BEEN VERY
EFFECTIVE. THIS PACKAGE WILL
ALLOW US TO CONTINUE THE GOOD
WORK AND MISTER CHAIRMAN I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU. I NEED TO
LEAVE YOUR STAFF THE SENATE
PRESIDENT PRO TEM ATKINS AND
HER STAFF. AND MISS SKINNER FOR
ALL OF YOUR GOOD WORK ON THIS
PACKAGE THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE APPRECIATE
COMMENTS NEXT IN THE COMMITTEE
MY MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I AM
IDEAL AND THE OTHER HALF OF THE
FATHER DAUGHTER TEAM
REPRESENTING THE LIBRARY
ASSOCIATION. I AM COMMENTING IN
SUPPORT OF THE PUBLIC LIBRARY
PACKAGE REGARDING THE PATRON
RELIEF. OF FIND THE ISSUE
LIBRARY FINES TOO OFTEN FALL
DISPROPORTIONATELY ON HARD ON
THOSE WHO CAN LEAST AFFORD TO
PAY THEM. A CLA HAS BEEN
ACTIVELY WORKING WITH YOUR
STAFF TO DETERMINE THE
UNIVERSITY OF THE FINES OWED
AND TO FIND A FORMULA FOR
CEALLAIGH CONVENED A WORKING
GROUP OF LEADERS INCLUDING THE
MONTEREY COUNTY LIBRARY
DIRECTOR. WHO BELIEVE THAT
RESURRECTION OF THE PUBLIC
LIBRARY FOUNDATION FOR THE
PURPOSE OF GIVING OUT THE
LIBRARY FIND RELIEF MONEY.
WOULD BE THE BEST OPTION VERY
QUICKLY THE PURPOSE OF THE PLF
WAS THE LIBRARY DE. BY PROPER.
THIRTEEN AND THEIR LOSS OF
PROPERTY TAXES. ORANGE COUNTY
LIBRARY WAS DEVASTATED
UNFORTUNATELY WHEN TIMES GOT
TOUGH THE MONEY WAS CUT AND
EVENTUALLY ELIMINATED EVERY
NICKEL. IF YOU USE THE PLF TO
ADDRESS THE FINES ISSUE YOU
WOULD. BE RESTORING THE PRIOR
CUTS TO LIBRARIES AND
ADDRESSING. THE FINES ISSUE AT
THE SAME TIME BY REQUIRING THAT
LIBRARIES WOULD HAVE TO
ELIMINATE FINES AS A CONDITION
OF RECEIVING THE FUNDS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I HAVE HEARD FROM THE
MONTEREY. LIBRARY SYSTEM. OF
OUR NO ONE ELSE IS IN THIS
ROOM- TWO PERCENT. ARE GO TO
TWENTY FORTY ROOM TWENTY FORTY
I SEE NO ONE AT THE PODIUM SO
MODERATOR- WE WILL NOW GO TO
YOU. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE
ONE FOUR ONE EIGHT FIVE THE
ACCESS CODE IS THREE THREE
EIGHT ZERO FOUR SIX SEVEN. NO
THIS IS THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
ANYBODY TO MAKE A COMMENT ON
ANY OF THE ITEMS THAT WE HAVE
HEARD TODAY- I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- AS YOU STATED TO COMMENT
ON ANY OF THE ITEMS TODAY
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AT THIS TIME AN EIGHTEEN
T. OPERATOR WILL GIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER OFFLINE IN THE PLACE
BACK IN THE QUEUE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO FOR PUBLIC COMMENT AT
THIS TIME. OUR FIRST
PARTICIPANT WILL BE LYING
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD AND
MODERATOR COULD YOU TELL ME HOW
MANY PEOPLE ARE IN THE QUEUE AT
THIS POINT. AT THIS POINT RIGHT
AROUND TWENTY SIR OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. FIFTEEN YOU ARE OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS FRANCO-
AND I AM THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
GRADUATE AND PROFESSIONAL
COUNCIL WHICH REPRESENTS MORE
THAN SIXTY THOUSAND GRADUATE
AND PROFESSIONAL STUDENT. WE
ARE IN AGREEMENT WITH THE UC
POSITION ON THE PROPOSAL TO CAP
NONRESIDENT SUPPLEMENTAL
TUITION- AND NON RESIDENT
INVOLVEMENT. BECAUSE THE STATE
DOESN'T DIRECTLY FUND GRADUATE
EDUCATION WE REQUIRE OUR
FUNDING DURING HER PROPERTY.
MANY GRADUATE STUDENTS ARE THEN
HIRED IN TEACHING ROLES AND
FUND THEIR EDUCATION IN THAT
WAY. THE PROPOSAL PUTS THAT
FUNDING AT RISK AND INTRODUCES
UNCERTAINTY TO THE EMPLOYMENT
AND FUNDING OF OUR GRADUATE
STUDENTS. RECENT STATE FUNDING
TO NOT HAVE A PROPER. DATA
SHOWN THEMSELVES ALL TOO
WILLING TO CUT FUNDING TO THE
UC APART THE BUDGET PRESSURE
AND THIS PROPOSAL WILL HAVE A
RIPPLE EFFECT ON EMPLOYMENT FOR
GRAD STUDENTS AND INTRODUCE
UNCERTAINTY INTO OUR ABILITY TO
SUPPORT OURSELVES. AND OUR
FAMILY. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH A MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU AT AT AFTER
RECOUNTED IS CLOSER TO FIFTEEN
MISTER CHAIR JUST TO LET YOU
KNOW HOW WE WERE GOING TO LINE
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING JOSH TAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY WE WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE CAL GRANT
EQUITY FRAMEWORK AS PROPOSED BY
THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT
EXHIBITION. CAL GRANT ACTUALLY
FREE MONTHLY BERMAN AREAS TO
FINANCIAL AID CREATED BY EACH
TIME OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL IN GPS.
TRACKING OVER TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY THOUSAND MORE STUDENTS
ELIGIBLE FOR. THE PARTICULAR
IMPORTANCE FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. STUDENTS
CURRENTLY RECEIVE JUST 7% OF
CAL GRANT DOLLARS DESPITE
SERVING TWO THIRDS OF THE STATE
COLLEGE STUDENT. AND THE
MAJORTY OF THE STATE'S
STUDENTS OF COLOR. ARE ALSO
IMPORTANT BUDGET INVESTMENTS TO
EXPAND CAPACITY AT THE TO GET
YOU SEE OUR RESEARCH REPORT
CALIFORNIA'S BIGGEST RETURN.
FIND THE CALIFORNIA WOULD
GENERATE. AN ADDITIONAL FOUR
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE. THANK
YOU GET BACK TO BY. THAT SIXTY
PER OF ADULT EACH RACIAL GROUP
HOW ALL DEGREE- HIGH GOT
PRODUCTION. EXPERIENCE CAPACITY
AND HIGHER EDUCATION WILL BE
QUITE IN MEETING THAT GOAL.
CALORIES STATES WERE TRYING TO
ECONOMIC PROSPERITY WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR DR
CAL GRANT AFTER THE FRAMEWORK
AND TO PRIORITIZE FUNDING TO
GROWING CAPACITY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. A
MODERATOR NEXT KOHLER. THANK
YOU WILL ALIGN FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CAMERAS
REPRESENTING THE NECK AND JUST
WHEN I WHEN OUR COMMENTS BUT
BE- FROM THAT COMPANY I BREAK
THIS PATIENT AND SAY WE'RE
REALLY. APPLIED THE SENATE
LEADERSHIP AND THEY'RE BUILT
BACK. WILL BE PROPOSAL YOU
INCREASE THE IN NOW HEALTH
STATE LAW. TO IMPROVE THEIR IN
INTACT AND WE LOOK TO-
INCLUDING BROADBAND THE PLANE
IN THE- THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS-
MATER NECK CALL. FIND TWENTY
YOUR- HELLO SURELY MY NAME
JOSHUA CHAIR OF RELEASE FOR
THESE STUDENTS AND JUNIOR YOU
CAN SPEAKING OF THE ON HOW READ
FIRST COLLEGE DID AND FINANCE
LEADERS TO I CAN GUARANTEE
QUALITY AND ACCEPT OF MY
EDUCATE TALK OR AS A RESULT OF
AN INDIVIDUAL CAP ON NON
RESIDENT MOMENT FRANKLY WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE CUTTING
RELATIVE VALUE WOULD BE FUN TO
PLAY SIMPLE METAL TO IT IN. THE
UC CONSIDERS THE TUITION MODEL
STUDENTS STAND UNITED AGAINST
IN THE CASE OF AN ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN THAT THE INABILITY TO
ADEQUATELY FUND YOU SEE WILL BE
TO ENACTED TUITION BURDEN BEING
PLACED ON STUDENT MAINTAIN THE
QUALITY OF THE INSTITUTION UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION IS DEEPLY
TROUBLED AND DISAPPOINTED IN
THE PROPOSAL BUT THE FACT IS
SUPPORT. FUNDING ROLE IN
INCREASES FUNDING FOR BIN AND
RETENTION SERVICES BUT DON'T
MAKE CURRENT COMPUTER UT
STUDENT THAT REFLECT THE
ACCEPTABILITY AND QUALITY OF
THEIR EDUCATION THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMMENTS. THE
MODERATOR MEXICO. FIND THIRTY
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING TURNER
MEMBER RON WRAPS NO BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION REPRESENTS
OVER TWENTY NINE THOUSAND
FACULTY INCLUDING TENURE TRACK
PROFESSORS LECTURERS LIBRARIANS
COUNSELORS AND COACHES FROM ALL
TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM- FIRST I WANT TO SAY WE
DEEPLY APPRECIATE THE AGREEMENT
BETWEEN THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO FULLY RESTORE
THE TWO HUNDRED NINETY NINE
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS. THE
CSU SUSTAINED IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT IN
ADDITION- WE APPRECIATE THE
BILL BACK BOLDLY PROPOSAL SO
LEMONADE- ANY UNDERLYING DEBT
TO THE CSU WE DO KNOW COULD BE
SEVERE REDUCTIONS IN REVENUE TO
THE CITY ISSUE BECAUSE TO GET
THE CAN CUTS TO COURSE
OFFERINGS AND FACULTY POSITIONS
WILL NEED TO RESTORE THOSE
POSITIONS ON COURSES IN ORDER
TO SERVE OUR STUDENTS WELL. IN
REGARDS TO ENROLLMENT FUNDING
COURSE YES YOU REMAINS BELOW
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY LEVELS
EVEN THOUGH STUDENT ENROLLMENT
HAS INCREASED SIGNIFICANTLY YES
SHE RECEIVED ELEVEN POINT NINE
BILLION IN TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY WITH AN ENROLLMENT OF
FOUR HUNDRED ELEVEN THOUSAND
STUDENTS SERVICE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY THESE ARE AYE I'VE
ALLOWED YOU TO GO CONSIDERABLY
OVER A MINUTE SO IF YOU WISH TO
SUBMIT ADDITIONAL COMMENTS TO
THE COMMITTEE PLEASE DO WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS.
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. TWENTY
AND ALLOW TWENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS A THERE'S NOTHING HAM I
MISHEARD YOU CHILE AND
PRESIDENT OF THE UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATION ON BEHALF OF THE
OVER TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND STUDENTS I REPRESENT
I'M HERE TO OPPOSE IN THE
STRONGEST TERMS ATTEMPTS TO CAP
NONRESIDENT ENROLLMENT AT UC.
TAPPING ON WRITTEN IN ROMAN
WITH EDUCATIONAL QUALITY FOR
BOTH CALIFORNIA STUDENTS AND
NON RESIDENT STUDENTS AND IF WE
WANT TO GROW CALIFORNIA'S
ALMOND AT UC THANK YOU WHAT
WORKS INVESTING IN ADDITIONAL
SEATS AND ACCESS PROGRAMS LIKE
THEY PERHAPS. BUILDING BACK
BOLDLY MEANS BUILDING BRIDGES
THE BROAD BASED OPPORTUNITY NOT
BUILDING WALLS TO KEEP CERTAIN
STUDENTS OUT HELLO STUDENTS
HAVE OFTEN SUPPORTED THE
COMMITTEE'S PROPOSALS TO
ENHANCE THE EDUCATION WE DON'T
SUPPORT THAT WE KNOW YOU CAN DO
BETTER AND THE APPS THE
BATHROOMS WILL CONTINUE TO
STRONGLY OPPOSE ANY ATTEMPT TO
CAP NONRESIDENT ENROLLMENT AND
KEEP OUR PEERS OUT FROM A
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMENTS. THE MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER. FIND PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING SHALLOW ON AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS NAY AUG GET
ON THE EDUCATION TRUST WHAT
FIRST I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU ALL
FOR TO THE HEARING AND
DISCUSSING ELIGIBLE RESOURCES
TO MAKE COLLEGE MORE AFFORDABLE
FOR STUDENTS. I'LL BE HAPPY TO
THAT WE ARE BACK IT'S BACK OUR
STRONG SUPPORTER CAL GRANT
EQUITY FRAMEWORK AS OPPOSED BY
SPEAKER- THE FRAMEWORK WOULD
REMOVE BARRIERS- TO FINANCIALLY
HM HIGH SCHOOL GPA TAKING OUR
SYSTEM MORE ACCESSIBLE TO
THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS WILL ALSO
STREAM ONE THREE FINANCIALLY TO
ABOUT THE NEED FOR STUDENTS-
CAL THE MODERNIZATION IS
DESPERATELY NEEDED AND THE
EQUITY BY LOOK REALLY AIMS TO
ATTRACT NEW NAPOLI CALLED BACK
TO THE NINETEEN. REALLY PUTS
YOU AT THE CENTER FURTHERMORE
WE BACKED OUT OF THE BACK IN
ORDER FOR ANYTHING TO HAPPEN TO
THE FINANCIAL WE HAVE NOW FOR
ANY FUTURE SYSTEM THAT WOULD
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
STUDENTS ARE APPLYING FOR THE
POPULAR JUDAH AND IF NEEDED
THEY HAVE THE SUPPORT TO GET
THIS DONE- THERE FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO ENSURE
THE L. YOU HAVE BEEN USED A LOT
THESE BONDS WITH VERY NEXT.
ALISA TODAY'S CONVERSATION- WE
URGE YOU TO ADOPT THE CHILD
THAT EQUITY BY WORK AND
PRIORITIZING BUSES BY STATE'S
FUTURE THAT IS OUR STUDENTS
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR COMMENTS. MODERATOR
NEXT CALLER. FIND SIX YOU ARE
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE BUDGET
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MARTIN YET
AND I AM A AT BUT CALIFORNIA
CRITICAL SHOP OFFICE. OR
ANYTHING YOU CAN TO HEARING TO
CONSIDER REFORM THE STATE'S AID
SYSTEM FOLLOW YOU SUPPORT A
ELIGIBILITY. WE BELIEVE THE
STATE SHOULD CRITICS THE CAL
GRANT TO MAKE IT IN THE TITLE
MATCH THAT COVERS TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE STUDENTS ATTENDING
COMMUNITY COLLEGE OUR STUDENTS
OFTEN STRUGGLE DON TUITION
COSTS INCLUDING FOOD
TRANSPORTATION TEXTBOOKS FROM
CHILD CARE IT NEEDS COST
CONSUMERS AN OPTICAL TOWARDS
COMPLETION WE ALSO WILL YOU
LEAVE THIS EXPANSION SHOULD BE.
FUNDED OUTSIDE OF PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT AND MAINTAIN THE
FUNDING INCLUDED IN THE STEP
PROCESS INCREASING GRAPH WE
THINK HE'S TRACKING DEVELOPING
CALVET EQUITY FRAMEWORK IN
LOOKS MORE TO WORKING WITH YOU
OVER THE COMING WEEKS ON OUR
CONCERNS THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS-
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. I AM
THIRTY TWO GOING. HI MY NAME IS
FINER- A DOCTOR AT U. K. AND
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE U.
FIFTEEN ASSOCIATION WITH A
COUPLE OF POINTS OF OPPOSITION-
REGARDING CAL GRANT FOUNDER THE
PROPOSAL. THE PROPOSAL DOES NOT
ADEQUATELY PEOPLE BY THE CAL
GRANT APPLICATION PROCESS-
WHICH MEANS THAT STUDENTS
DESERVING OF IT WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO ACTUALLY TALK ABOUT
THAT I ONE OF THE CORE ASPECT
OF THE CONGRESS ACTUALLY
FRAMEWORK TO DRAMATICALLY
SIMPLIFY THEY FINANCIAL AID. TO
STUDENTS ARE ACTUALLY ABLE TO
NAVIGATE FINANCIAL PROFIT AND
WONDER STAND FOR PACKAGE  HAVE
A CONTRACT WITH THEM OR ARE YOU
KEEP THAT. SECOND WITHOUT
EXPANDING AID ELIGIBILITY IN
REMOVING OUTDATED BARRIERS THE
PROPOSAL WILL ALLOW GAPS IN
COVERAGE TO CONTINUE TO
TOLERATE AGREED FRAMEWORK WOULD
EXPAND ACCESS TO HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS. AND
BETTER TARGET AGE POPULATION
THE NEED- THE LEGISLATURE
ALREADY HAD THE BILL- IT BEFORE
TO PROTECT THAT COMPREHENSIVELY
ADDRESSES ISSUES CAL GRANT- AND
WE ARE DEPENDENT TO SUPPORT
THAT- IN SUPPORT THE CORRECTLY
SO. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS. A
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. FOURTEEN
YOUR UP PLEASE GOING. YES GOOD
CARE LEARNED AND- MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE LET'S BEGIN
MERKLEY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU- THOUGH IT WAS NOT
AGAIN DIES TODAY UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AGON NATURAL
RESOURCES HAS BEEN A CASUALTY.
OF A LONG TERM BUDGET CUTS AND
YET PROVIDE THE COMPONENTS-
POLICE TO WORK OF NATURAL AND
WORKING LANDS NEED TO MEET THE
STATE'S CLIMATE PAST
COMPARTMENTAL AND ECONOMICAL SO
ON BEHALF OF A BROAD COALITION
OF AGRICULTURAL LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND CONSERVATION
ORGANIZATIONS WE ASK AND
SUBSEQUENT HEARINGS THIS
COMMITTEE CONSIDER AN
ADDITIONAL THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS ONGOING FOR UC ANR TO
CREATE A SUSTAINABLE. HELP WAY
FOR PROGRAM DELIVERY THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMENTS MODERATOR NEXT COSTS.
NINE TWENTY TWO YOUR OPEN. BY
SATURDAY THANK YOU SO MUCH- I'M
HERE TODAY TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE COPPER
NONRESIDENT INVOLVEMENT MY NAME
IS REAL MONSTER I'LL BE SENDING
YOU CAN MAKE THE EXTERNAL
AFFAIRS BY PRESIDENT I KEEP
KEEP BERKELEY AND I'M ALSO NON
RESIDENT STUDENTS I HAVE A
NONRESIDENT ENROLLMENT HARM
BOTH CALIFORNIA AND NON
RESIDENTS INSIDE DECREASING THE
OVERALL QUALITY OF THE IPC
EDUCATION. I WOULD LIKE I COULD
SENTIMENT FACT BECAUSE HAD
MENTIONED ABOUT WANTING HIM
BACK AND EXPANDED INVOLVEMENT
YOU SEE I'M FUNNY PROGRAM BUT
THEY THOUGHT THAT A LOT MORE
CALIFORNIANS YEAH YOU SEE
EDUCATION AND PREPARING THEM
FOR HIGHER AT ITS APPALLING TO
ME TO THINK THAT DIDN'T LIKE ME
ARE NOT GONNA GET AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HUNT YOU SEE
WHAT WE CAN HAVE ALTERNATIVE
NOT THAT. OTHER CALIFORNIANS TO
COME TO THE SCHOOL AS WELL I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO SAY THAT I
AM PLANNING TO BECOME A
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT AFTER UC
BERKELEY ON THE PLAN TO ATTEND
MEDICAL SCHOOL IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I WORK CALIFORNIA
JOBS I AM ATTENDING HERE IN
BERKELEY AND SO MANY
NONRESIDENTS COMING CONTRIBUTE
TO THE ECONOMY AND WE WANT TO
CONTINUE DOING THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMENTS. A MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER. THANK U. S. CHAIR WILL
ALIGN TWENTY SO. I THINK MY
CHAIR BETWEEN ALLEN ON THE HAVE
OF THE CALIFORNIA HIRED.
COALITION A GROUP COMPLY OF
EDGE OF ALL RIGHT BUSINESS WITH
THE STUDENT COMMUNITY BASED. AS
YOU LIKE IT OUR STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THE CAL ACNE CREAM MARK THE
BY THE K. EIGHT NATION ARE
GOING TO REMARKS CALL IN THE OF
THE CAL GRANT EXCLUDES BREMER
THE PROPOSAL MOST SIGNIFICANT
BARRIERS TO FINANCIAL AID AND
ENSURE COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY
FAST. CALIFORNIANS AND
DOCUMENTATION INCLUDING AN
ESTIMATED EIGHTY SEVEN THOUSAND
UNDOCUMENTED IMPROPER PUBLIC
HIGHER AND SOME PARTICULAR
SEVEN THOUSAND OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES BELONG. EVERYWHERE
SENATE ASSEMBLY AND GOT MANAGER
DR CAL GRANT THE FREE. MARKET
HI ERIC HOW. FOR THE STATE
MOBILE STUDENTS IN OUR AND OUR
STUDENTS TO MAKE CON AND OUR
GREAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR COM SMALL NEXT
CALL. NINE THIRTY OR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MORE CHERYL AND IS GRANT
A UNDER OF THE CENTRE DUNDEE WE
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT INCLUSION HOW GREAT
EQUITY FRAMEWORK AND HERBS
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THE
NECESSARY INVESTMENTS HOW GRANT
TO AVAILABLE FOR ALL DELL
ELIGIBLE COLLEGE YOU THINK
FORGET THE NEEDS. THAT
ARTIFICIAL. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COM- MODERATOR CALL. THANK YOU
KNOW JUST GIVE A FINAL REMINDER
TO A QUEUE UP PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO FOR PUBLIC
COMMENTS NEXT TO A LINE THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING SURE LAYERED
SENATORS MY NAME'S GUANLONG
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
STREET LOCATION THE OFFICIAL
VOICE OF. THE STRINGS. WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE CURRENT
EQUITY FRAMEWORK WHICH IS
REFLECTED IN THE ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX THE BASIC
NEEDS CRISIS IN THE CSU SYSTEM
IS BROKE. REALLY HAVE A LOT OF
PERCENT OF OUR STUDENTS ARE
HOMELESS. AND 42% ARE DEALING
WITH THE FOOD SECURITY. CAMERA
MODERNIZATION IS DESPERATELY
NEEDED TO HELP OUR STUDENTS PAY
FOR THEIR TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE. BOTH CHAMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATURE HAS MADE
FINANCIALLY PERFORMER PRIORITY.
AND NOW IS THE TIME ABOUT THE
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN WE HOPE THE
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY WILL COME
TOGETHER TO ATOP THE CALORIE
INTACT THE PRIMARK. AND
PRIORITIZED INVESTMENTS IN THE
CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE WORKFORCE
OUR CURRENT STUDENTS THANK YOU
FOR TALKING. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS.
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. THIRTY FOR
POLICE AHEAD. I ENTERED ON
BEHALF OF THE STUDENT SENATE
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES OFFICIAL VOICE TO THE
TWO POINT ONE MILLION COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS OUR SYSTEM
RECEIVED 7% OF TARGA RESOURCES
BY SERVING TWO THIRDS OF THE
STUDENTS WE STRONGLY URGE YOU
TO ADOPT THE CALVERT EQUITY
FRAMEWORK I SUPPOSE THAT THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION. YEARS OF RESEARCH
AND CONSULTATION WITH ALL
RELEVANT STAKEHOLDERS WHEN INTO
THIS PLAN IN STRONG WINDS THE
SENATE BOLD PROPOSAL TO ADDRESS
COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY BETWEEN
SURE STATE BENEFIT PROGRAM
PRIORITIZE LOW INCOME STUDENTS
AND STOPS DISCRIMINATING
AGAINST STUDENTS BECAUSE OF
ARCANE. RATIONING MECHANISMS
THANK YOU. THANK VERY MUCH. OUR
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. NINE
THIRTY SIX YOU ARE OPEN.
MORNING MR CHEN MEMBERS
CONSTANTLY ON BEHALF OF U. A.
W. TWENTY FIVE AND FIFTY EIGHT
TEN WE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
DECREASING NONRESIDENT
ENROLLMENTS AT UC ATTRACTING
HIGH QUALITY APPLICANTS AND
WELCOMING A DIVERSE GROUP OF
SCHOLARS FROM ACROSS THE WORLD
MAKES YOU FEEL WORLD CLASS
INSTITUTION WE DON'T WANT NEW
RESTRICTIONS ON NON RESIDENT
MISSION THE THREATEN UC'S
QUALITY OR DIVERSITY. WE
UNDERSTAND THE NEED FOR A
HIGHLY EDUCATED WORKFORCE IN
CALIFORNIA BUT WE KNOW THAT
THOUSANDS OF NON RESIDENT
STUDENT EVERY YEAR REMAIN IN
CALIFORNIA JOIN THE WORK FORCE
NONRESIDENTS THE INTER HELPING
MEET THE STATE- MANY OF OUR
INTERNATIONAL MEMBERS WENT TO
COLLEGE NHÍP BEFORE GOING ON
TO ATTEND YOU SEE AS GRAD
STUDENTS OR POST DOCS. AND MANY
CLIENTS REMAIN IN THE U. S. AND
RAISE THEIR FAMILIES HERE- AND
WE'VE HEARD FROM MANY ON THIS
CALL WHO ARE ATTEMPTING TO
THAT- WE BELIEVE INCREASING YOU
THINK ON INCREASE RESIDENT
MOMENT WITHOUT IMPLEMENTING A
NEW CAP SYSTEM WOULD BE A
BETTER PLAN TO MEET THE CURRENT
WORKFORCE NEEDS THAT THE STATE
HAS AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
TALKING MORE ABOUT THIS ISSUE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OUR MODERATOR. NEXT CALLER.
NINE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE MORNING CARE AIRED
IN- NUMBERS SAMANTHA SAYING
WITH EXCHANGE. WANTED TO ECHO
THE COMMENTS TO SUPPORT THE
EQUITY FRAMEWORK LAID OUT BY C.
SACK AND ALSO APPRECIATE THE
SENATE BILL BACK WILL BE PLAN
TO ADDRESS THE FULL SPECTRUM OF
STUDENTS IN THE COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY LINES INCLUDING
LOOKING AT ALLEVIATING STUDENT
DEBT FOR THOSE WHO ARE
CURRENTLY REPAYMENT THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMENTS MODERATOR NEXT CALLER.
AND WE WERE LINE THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S
ALEX NILES- BOARD MEMBER OF THE
UC STUDENTS ASSOCIATION
UNFORTUNATE SEVEN BILLION DOES
NOT ADEQUATELY ADDRESS THE
CURRENT ISSUE CAL GRANT
INCLUDING SIMPLE FIND
APPLICATION PROCESS AND
EXPANDING ELIGIBILITY. WE URGE
THE SENATE TO PASS AB FOURTEEN
FIFTY SIX AS A IT WILL
EFFECTIVELY SOLVE THOSE
PROBLEMS THANK YOU THANK YOU-VERY MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE EXHAUSTED THE
QUEUE. WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I APPRECIATE YOUR HELP TODAY
MODERATOR- GOOD GOOD JOB OF
THAT COMPLETES THE BUSINESS IN
FRONT OF THE COMMITTEE OWES ASK
ANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE ANY
LAST COMMENTS. THE END OF OR ME
THANK EVERYBODY WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY AND IF YOU
WEREN'T ABLE TO TESTIFY OR YOU
WANTED TO SUBMIT THINGS IN
ADDITIONAL ADDITIONALLY TO WHAT
YOU SAID. PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE BECAUSE THESE
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US WE WANT TO
INCLUDE THE TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL RECORDS AND- THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION. THANKS
FOR EVERYBODY FOR THEIR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION WE'VE
AND CONCLUDED THE AGENDA FOR
TODAY'S HEARING THE SENATE
BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER ONE STANDS
ADJOURNED.